e
[Musique]
alors
[Applaudissements]
o'keeffe
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
mais
nulle sur le plateau de tout le monde en
parle l'émission qui parle avec nous ce
soir
jean-noël euros dany boon
la semaine
moncorgé gabin
la science sur les people à
nabab
ce sens
[Musique]
les islamistes nous revoir
le salut en prada
à quand le retour
il teste vocaux
mais engagée
[Applaudissements]
non
s'il voit roland garros à la tv sur
france 2 et françois l'après midi non
c'est vraiment le genre qui prépare déjà
la retraite je vais au match de tennis
je ne prends rien [ __ ] rien branler
pas évident quand on est hyper actif
comme moi je vais aller ça valait très
bientôt une très bonne idée pour les
tableaux thierry tu peux nous en parler
oui l'idée des tableaux c'est vrai alors
voilà tous les tableaux qui sont ici
vous pouvez les acheter au profit de
l'oeuvre de stéphanie fugain les
claquettes
il suffit d'aller sur un site où monde
en parle et puis voilà vous les achetez
ce sera un prix unique 1 c'est plus
simple non non non ce pas plus sain
parce que voir les étoiles quand même
qu'ils seront plus chers que d'autres
photos de chaque toile bah oui ça nous
irrite agl ça va perdre de la valeur
c'est sûr et les gens vont monter les
enchères sur chaque toile assure chaque
chien la toile
laurent guerry qu'est-ce qu'on fait
avant de recevoir notre premier invité
d'habitude on regarde le best of de la
semaine dernière et actuellement et s'y
préparer par qui pas un connard navarro
d'accord tu vas tu as changé mais non si
j'osais 7e jose mari était au serge
il ya un moment dans la vie où on a la
foi je dirais la maîtrise on croit tout
cas avoir la maîtrise des choses et puis
on se fait virer comme des merdes
cependant les jeudis je deviens un petit
peu sourd une autre quel est celui ou
celle qui par son expérience
connaissance de l'appareil d'état et
puis je dirais son imagination c'est sa
vision
pardon pour le maître survie jackson là
ça va être un enfer c'est la particule
l'acculent profit des jeux tels que vous
ayez quelques l'obs d'addiction vous
avez écrit alors demandé du respect de
l'éthique non absolument il m'a répondu
par une lettre amical
tu as raison et là c'est moins deux
volets
résume les gens centimes c'est moi
qu'ils ne foulent pas je résume alors la
principale mesure de jack lang pour le
chômage pour vaincre le chômage c'est
que c'est de faire une grande fête du
chômage ou les gens descendraient qu ils
sont descendus dans la rue étaient
chômeurs pour danser malheureusement la
'national à des progrès sort commencé à
corriger ce cas et que je rate ou gauche
danse a été pratiquement la même sinon
si vous savez nous ayons bien le nom que
j'ai proposé à françois hollande que
nous facilitions les conditions
d'adhésion 20 euros sur internet
essabah et ça marche j'accueille 0
d'habitude c'est la vie d'une jeune evry
comme ça donc en tout cas avant jeudi
voilà 20 euros vous cliquez mieux vos
clics et recevoir une claque comme en
2002 l'a appelé il ya très longtemps me
souvenais jack nous sommes nous nous
sommes appelés mais nous ne sommes pas
amis
on peut le devenir rodez sont nés mes
cartes on aura tout essayé
vous devez supplier patrick de carolis
de vous reprendre
tu arrives à le faire bon ils ont pensé
quoi de la france d'aujourd'hui là elle
s'en remettra ouais l'année prochaine si
on veut me donner une île entourée de
requin où on mettra ou en mettra les
condamnés à mort ensemble et y trouver
et ils font eux mêmes leurs polices et
bah voilà bon quand même
c'est le bagne que vous décrivez
l'instant vous savez vous savez ce qu'a
été la monstruosité du bad
vous n'avez pas été assassinés donc vous
ne savez pas ce que c'est qu'à
monstruosité la tête il est bientôt
c'est le charme de cette émission
j'aurais vu jouer star celi côte à côte
avec maurice mais on se mettait aussi
rêvent aussi pour me c'est pour moi
préfèrent comme sayo vous devez chanter
une chanson de bruel en la massacre ans
on s'était dit rendez vous d'art dida
mais je
seo est venue des grands-hommes excuse
est radin au point de mettre de l'eau du
robinet dans des bouteilles d'eau
minérale
non jamais non parce que je connais une
très bonne excuse les traits d'un point
de demander une prostituée de vous
rendre la monnaie
c'est pas un sport que je pratique vous
en trouvez pas non c'est trop cher
francis récemment dans paris match vous
avez avoué avoir découvert l'amour avec
un garçon ce qui est quand c'est d'aimer
quelqu'un c'est pas avec quel sexe on va
les mecquois ouais ouais non mais moi
moi si tu veux ce garçon j'y pense tous
les jours de ma vie tu as quelque chose
à lui dire la cité regard bas merci mais
t'as rien fait un bassiste
est-ce que vous jouez parfait de la
guitare à quatre heures du matin dans un
arbre ouais alors aussi c'est incroyable
ça te fait rire mais est ce que je vis
nana maire adjoint et didier ça fait
sans déconner ça te fait rire mais ça
l'aigle et pourquoi ça te fait rire
c'est mon petit francis est ce que vous
ai déjà eu envie de mettre votre sexe
dans un trou pour faire l'amour avec la
terre et coûteux après avoir chanté dans
l'arbre aux kora balafon ce qu'ils font
l'amour dans la terre c'est parce qu'il
ya une taupe c'est bon on va y aller
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'accueille laura smet et florence
moncorgé gabin
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
laurence et passe alors à sa recherche
s'est pas laissée pas les bonnes places
laurent je leur ai dit mes épaules
inversée si les aurait changé de place
on recense deux places bon on va la
refaire
mais là j'étais fait piéger par laurent
avec formidable il ya un ferme
c'est marrant parce que ce soir je
reçois la fille de johnny hallyday et la
fille de jean gabin j'aurais pu faire
faire l'interview par ma fille commence
à valora alors voilà je vais te dire
laurent ça fait six mois qu'elle me dit
quand je viendrai dans ton émission pour
le field de florence dû t'en supplie ne
me mets pas la chanson l'oral en tunisie
alors tu vois c'est fait pareil je t'ai
pas dit non mais tu le dis ouais faut
pas que je le dise si si si si j'adore
tu n'aimes cette chanson tu les aimes
ton papa n'a manqué à ton papa et à
maman écoute ça dépend des jours non si
j'aime beaucoup la chanson mais bon
c'est vrai que ça ne pas nous très à
l'aise tout de suite
ouais non puis c'est une chanson que tu
as entendu en fait dans un concert tu
avais six ans est ce qu on a tout le
monde tu as regardé et c'était un peu
traumatisé mais j'espère que oui il y
avait d'un coup tout bercy tu vas qui se
retourne vers toi à 6 ans et sur ce qui
se passe tu vois que tu supportes rémy
aujourd'hui oui si tu es à côté de moi
tout va bien sympa ce que veulent ils
je peux aller voter
on est on est pas là pour parler de vos
parents à toutes les deux on est là pour
parler du film de florence dans lequel
tu joues ça s'appelle le passager de
l'été avec catherine frot mathilde
seigner grégori derangère françois
berléand et toi le roi ce soir le 7 juin
tu fasses le pitch florence où tu veux
le faire à vue non moi j'ai pas envie de
le faire nous apprend rien sinon je peux
le faire je vais être moins bien et le
toit je fasse un pub à west ham et le
film ouais ben c'est pas mal d alors
voilà heureusement je vais le faire le
pitch c'est un peu théorème à le film de
pasolini
c'est une ferme dans les années 50 après
la guerre il n'y a pas d'homme parce que
beaucoup sont morts au combat
mais le mari de la patronne catherine
frot lui les partis avec une gueuse
voilà il ya trois femmes dans cette
ferme
il ya catherine frot donc des grands
mères y alors à qui la fille de
catherine frot voilà et à ce moment là
arrive à un ouvrier saisonnier joué par
grégori derangère et il va les aimer
toutes les deux c'est à dire catherine
frot et laura et là c'est exactement
c'est une triangulaire qui est qu'il ya
eu maldonne nous dévoile puisque la mère
admire l'ouvrier à cause de son travail
et que nuit admire la jeune par le
savoir que lui n'a pas démontré la papa
la grand mère c'est peut-être suite
je sais pas ça il faudrait qu'une
génération c'est pas mal alors que
florence vous avez été levée à la
campagne vous ça se sent pourtant quand
on voit le film ah oui j'ai été assez
exigeante sur sur tout ce qui touche la
gestuelle et puis et puis les détails de
la campagne
c'est quelque chose que j'ai bien connu
puis vous savez j'ai beaucoup d'amis qui
habite la campagne qui sont agriculteurs
ou qui travaillent dans l'élevage
donc ils m'ont dit attention tu attends
on t'attend au tournant donc il fallait
faire attention quand même mais votre
père il était agriculteur en fait c'est
un paysan jabbar gaieté il était paysan
qui l'a commencée gabart en 53 avec avec
quelques lapins et un année en 76 il
avait 300 têtes de bétail et 15 chevaux
de course
enfin les chevaux de course c'était
quand même une danseuse alors que le
bétail c'est quelque chose qui bonhomme
alors apporte toujours son son prix quoi
vous savez traire les vaches
oui j'ai appris des ans tous deux sous
mais curieusement je n'ai pas appris
avec chez mon père parce qu'il va venir
la traite electric ge a pas sur un film
qui s'appelle les granges brûlées que
j'ai tourné avec de longs et signoret et
là on m'a appris à travailler car on ne
savait alors justement là c'est un film
qui se passe au moment de l'arrivée de
la mécanisation à la la campagne c'est à
dire qu'à le premier tracteur tout ça
mais encore beaucoup de choses qui sont
assez archaïque dans le film à l'époque
où on était donc on est arrivé à la
campagne
il y avait encore des percherons qui
travaillaient ils sont restés quand même
très longtemps ses chevaux et j'ai vu
ces gens travailler comme ça très dure
derrière les chevaux la charrette tout
ça et puis j'ai vu l'arrivée du tracteur
qu'on voit dans le film le massey
ferguson il y avait aussi des renault
mais c'était surtout les masses fr lui
sommes en avait deux à la maison et ça a
révolutionné le monde agricole
complètement alors il ya une espèce de
sexualité sous jacente dans ce film
c'est que des regards que des gens qui
sait quand il traite des vaches et le
real non c'est vrai
catherine frot c'est la première fois
que je vois comme ça moi elle est très
très sexy dans ce film oui mais c'était
le c'était le but atteindre résidant à
oui bravo hein
vous l'avez rendu sexy désirable c'était
c'était le but à atteindre et c'est
effectivement ce qui laisse qu'elle
craignait le plus parce que catherine
est quelqu'un de très pudique que très
très pudique mais je ne pensais pas à ce
point là parce que c'est vrai que on en
avait quand même très peu parlé avant le
film on en avait un petit peu parlé mais
pas beaucoup
et quand on est arrivés justement les
journées où il a fallu tourner ses
scènes j'ai bien senti qu'il y avait
quelques avec il y avait des choses
qu'il a qui la gêne est quand même mais
j'ai dit catherine faut y arriver parce
que c'est moi c'est le point culminant
quand même de mon film ce n'est pas ça
le film peut tomber à plat donc c'était
très important
il ya un moment elle est allongée dans
le lilla ya le mec arrive à luz sont
liés à lui fait un regard j'aurais
jamais pensé que j'allais désir et
catherine frot à la très désirable
c'est ça ah oui oui elle a réussi
quelque chose d'extraordinaire alors
évidemment il ya mathilde seigner bon le
couche avec tout le monde mais ça c'est
la vie non non dans le film mais ça
c'est un scoop c'est assez voilà c'est
plus attendu que catherine frot voilà ce
que je veux dire
ben oui oui au rial aura alors ma chère
leur a le look cinq ans nous va très
très bien
vous êtes magnifique dans ce film très
héroïne de roman et alors vous jouez le
rôle d'une institutrice alors ça c'est
vraiment un rôle de composition parce
que l'orage changer d'école à peu près
tous les bijoux et on le sait ni lire ni
un rôle de proposer pourquoi vous
changer l'école parce que vous en aviez
marre que tous les élèves vous dise ah
que coucou parce que non non non parce
que je n'arrivais pas à rentrer dans le
moule scolaire c'est vraiment un truc
moi quand je suis obligé de faire
quelque chose je ne le fais pas voilà et
donc leurs alliés pas arriver leur art
et essai en coin
voilà c'est ça pas mal non mais c'est
pas mal mais en tout cas c'était en tout
cas pour moi de faire ce film là
j'espère que mes profs
venir ici oui et voilà donc non c'était
amusant pour moi espèce de revanche pas
je me suis si j'arrive à faire ça
j'arriverai peut-être à faire des trucs
qui m'impressionne vont encore plus vous
êtes très bien dans le film alors c'est
vrai que le cinéma c'est c'est différent
c'est la première fois vous dites que
j'arrive à terminer quelque chose
avant c'était une horreur j'arrive à
rien finir même pas un livre avant et
c'est vrai que quand je pars en c'est un
livre je finissais même pas les
dernières pages je sais pas j'avais un
truc que j'aime bien ne pas finir les
choses et là tu es obligé parce que tu
vas chanter sous contrat il ya trop
chambrer à florence pourquoi me fais le
premier film à votre âge par un autre
âge à notre âge je disais à votre âge
vous de dire qu'on a pas longtemps
wenger alors pourquoi on fait un film
à notre âge ben parce qu'on fait quel
âge exactement continent leva situant
laurent ça se fait pas demander là je
suis maintenant six semaines que celui
de thierry moi j'ai absolument aucune
image de moi je moi je trouve thierry en
pleine forme donc oui oui il a beaucoup
baissé il a eu des mauvaises nouvelles
récemment et là
alors pourquoi pourquoi santé à cet âge
non pourquoi si tard florent soit si
tard alors pourquoi si tard justement
parce que en fait je moi j'ai réalisé
mon premier court métrage donc en 86
j'avais dans l'idée de continuer après
ce court métrage justement à écrire ou
ou de refaire un court métrage ou de
faire un long métrage
et puis s'est trouvé que ma vie un petit
peu changé et que j'ai rencontré
quelqu'un avec qui je suis parti habiter
la campagne ils ont encore presque
inverse hâtivement 1re à lorient un
plouc
voilà comme les parisiennes disent
exactement à mettre les moyens
voilà donc nous sommes allés il dans le
courrier n'est pas d'accord ouais et moi
pendant quinze ans je me suis retiré
complètement du monde du cinéma donc
j'ai absolument pas pensé par contre
j'ai écrit pendant ce temps là j'ai pas
perdu mon temps mais je n'ai j'ai pas
fait de j'ai pas réalisé c'est en
rentrant à paris après que heureusement
que c'est terminé
ce nouveau ce film exactement ça très
bien construit c'est pareil tout chaud
jean marie demain quitter comme ça au
moins j'ai fait une chose intéressante
lorsque vous allez faire maintenant
toutes les deux je vais regarder votre
caméra celle où yann rouge permis
les dires mais n'était serge ensemble
attention sinon ça marche pas attention
non la caméra florence est une cale
rouge
attention rôle aura un deux trois
magnéto serge magique
qu'est ce que vous voulez je cherche du
travail on m'a dit qu'il y aurait
peut-être si vous qui vous ai dit ça un
gars sur le chemin message du mois
[Musique]
j'espère vous n'êtes pas feignant ça
veut dire que c'est oui
[Musique]
joseph on mettrait de côté deux sauts
pour le beurre et fromage plan vous
savez les faire les fromages blancs
bonjour maman
bonjour ma fille c'est que la musique
est là un nouveau comme il est alors
question que ça me fout tu sers beau
gâchis
c'est même un sacré bestiaux donc aimé
ta directement ou quoi paypal à mener
lui-même sont là j'ai rêvé j'ai pas le
souvenir que j'en ai fait autant pour
fernand ces tout petits sites ou set
mais je suis sûr que tout le monde pense
qu'on va coucher ensemble jamais eu de
premiers soins et danse bien le commune
tamer est pas mal à 10 dont il se prend
pas pour une merde et lé nom singulier
et là non plus rien je disais moi ça par
exemple pourquoi est ce qu'il est parti
qui sort votre mari ça vous regarde pas
c'est mon employé joseph
vers lui
[Musique]
joseph
non exactement
annick ya des choses qui me plaisent pas
tu apprends à lire et à écrire
c'est un crime va lui servir à quoi on
désherber
bien je l'aimais
main et je t'aime
voilà le passager de l'été de florence
moncorgé gabin avec leurs fenêtres
entre autres qui nous invite ce soir
voilà c'est priori dérangère ils sont un
peu à gabin dans l'est dans les films
des années 30 ou 40 ah ça oui je trouve
j'étais simple nature comme ça
authentique authentique c'est peut-être
pas un hasard
ouais certainement pas un hasard il est
porteur de valeurs qui avaient à
l'époque faut pas oublier non plus quand
50 y avait certaines valeurs qui
n'existe plus maintenant
et peut-être que ces valeurs là rappelle
le gamin d'entre les deux guerres c'est
ça voilà c'est un titre qui bosse en
bosse en bosse est à l'époque et avait
pas les 35 heures vous trouvé séduisant
vos grégori derangère par son talent en
tout cas tu te mouilles pas beaucoup la
non sévère que je trouve très beau mc je
regarde pas trop les hommes sur leur
attention attention non non je suis dire
que non mais oui mais en tout cas c'est
vrai que de travailler avec lui c'est
quelqu'un de très généreux et voilà
c'est un peu la première fois je trouve
vraiment beaucoup beaucoup de plaisir à
travailler c'est clair
non mais vraiment je veux dire tu te
trouve séduisant ou pas oui beaucoup de
plaisir les rapports avec bd par exemple
a rien à voir c'est le travail c'est
vraiment bidon gélules gala moi bah non
mais tu l'as dit voilà en gros c'est à
lui ses sorties ah oui tu as dit que le
premier vrai je t'aime de ta vie c'était
frédéric c'est vrai c'est vrai il ya de
l'argent à se faire les dents tu as dis
je pourrais faire n'importe quoi par
amour non mais c'est formidable
attention je peux faire n'importe quoi
en tout doute aussi par amour voilà
c'est ça il est jaloux des acteurs
frédéric non en tournée il ne montre pas
ah oui quand tu étais avec grégori
derangère là il n'était pas non il ne
montre pas du tout j'aimerais bien qu'il
soit plus jaloux d'ailleurs si l'on
regarde soit un tout petit peu plus
jaloux un garçon mais en même temps tu
dis quand on me demande de faire l'amour
à l'écran il faut pas faire la fine
bouche
bats pas tu nous on lit un scénario et
qu'on dit oui pour un rôle et qu'on la
lui et que c'est pas gratuit et que pour
les corps impatients il y avait une
scène à 3 g pas assez c'est pas si ça a
à voir avec l'histoire il n'ya pas ok
une histoire quoi un porno cas bon
scénario
avec toute façon il a déclaré dans la
fiction on peut réaliser toutes nos
envies
formidable non bien enfin on ne suit pas
on va pas passer la soirée avec non mais
t'as bien encore 12 presque comme ça on
va pas parce que soit idiot ni et
frédéric et tous ces annonces on va
faire un hardi view
alors vous pensez à quoi en ce moment
j'ai un peu peur de tes questions quand
vous regarder dans la glace le matin
vous dites quoi je parle rarement à moi
même le matin même pour te parler tu
aurais aimé ressembler à qui quand tu
étais petit
vanessa paradis
ah ouais je les adore depuis tout le
temps toujours ouais t'as plus belle
histoire d'amour en ce moment ah ouais
mais moins pour vivre heureux vivons
cachés on va dire ça comme ça
ouais est-ce que tu serais prête à tout
quitter pour le grand amour ta carrière
tu es parents la france
ta religion oui
ah oui
oui mais je pense que si même il ne
donnera pas quand on demande une
autographes tu signes ou quoi ls je suis
pas toi comme ça les gens peuvent
s'imaginer qu'un programme de l'usiné à
nice
quand est-ce que tu as pleuré pour la
dernière fois alors c'était à cannes
pour la projection de marie-antoinette
tout à fait pleurer et huawei mais
pourtant il la tue pas dans le film
oui mais aussi pour ça que ça m'a fait
pleurer ouais tu l'as et messieurs j'ai
adoré ah ouais ouais c'est la première
personne que je vois qu'il j'avais lu
l'autobiographie g soit j'adore ça vire
cette femme et ça et c'est vrai que le
film trouve que c'est déjà d'une beauté
incroyable
et oui j'ai été très ému je sais pas
pourquoi qu'est-ce que tu changerais en
toi si tu avais une baguette magique
j'essaierai transformer mon angoisse en
sérénité
mais peut-être que je m'ennuierais plus
sympa quel péché qui vous tente le plus
la paresse et oui et je le sais et je le
sais parce que frédéric maladie qu'est
ce que vous pourriez y en avait plus
négatives sur vos bons en ce moment j'ai
accepté des sacs gratuits
pas mal c'est un petit peu honteux donc
j'essaie de les donner
d'accord mais c'est assez négative c'est
bien si notre vie était à refaire
qu'est-ce que vous changeriez sans doute
dès l'adolescence
parce que c'est arrivé tôt ça a duré
trop longtemps et c'est un âge que je
trouve très ingrat je recommencerai pas
ça ouais
quelle insulte qui t'a fait le plus mal
à part madame beigbeder qui fait
je crois que c'était à l'école ce cas un
prof qui m'avait dit que qu'avec mon nom
j'avais pas besoin de faire des études
et c'est pour ça que ça m'a appelé c'est
parce que sa vérité blesse qui as-tu le
plus envie d'épater dans la vie mes
parents mais qui la mer oui comme
téléphone sonne t heureuse ou agacer ses
dépens quel nom s'affiche
quelle est la dernière chose que tu fais
le soir avant de te coucher leur à
l'amour ça défile aujourd'hui je porte
ma contient pas de film qu'est-ce que tu
ferais site rester 24 heures à vivre
pareil pendant 24 heures d'accord quel
est le surnom qu'on te donne que tu es
croire non je suis obligé de dire ça
c'est new new new new york c'est
horrible miou-miou ces visas pour éviter
non je dirai pas qui en tout cas on va
faire un deal était le dire on s'appelle
pas non non non c'est compris mieux qu
est la dernière personne que tu envie de
tuer quand tu dis toi tu parles de new
york
et dieu dans tout ça
j'y crois pas ah bon mais je pense à
céret qu'il n'ya pas longtemps j'ai dans
mon bain j'essaye de réciter notre père
c'est bien comme endroit c'était
bénitier géant c'est bien ça c'était un
non mais ça part d'un bon sentiment mais
tu viens tu vois que tu as fait du bien
ouais continue qu'est ce que la vie vous
a appris à être heureux c'est maintenant
ou jamais certains nous présente le
bonheur comment aimerais tu mourir c'est
pas comme jim morrison dans un bain
quel est le mot que tu ne supporte pas
d'entendre pargneaux bien fait je crains
le plus ému
en ce moment c'est clearstream ah ouais
parce que je trouve ça laid entendre à
leur ex pas le français ouais ouais ça
me gonfle comprend pas très bien ce qui
s'est passé en fait rien gêné en plus
t'es pas tout seul est-ce que tu as
menti pendant cette interview je suis
comédienne
[Musique]
kaba avec ghazi
soit à berlin
un des trois quarts
à cartes et johnny vous devez chanter
lors à optic 2000
bien sûr la guerre vers l'accueil des
deux ans et demi c'est cuit pour bazire
tu vas pas je mettrai le rating demi
de quoi faire
non
et
atol les opticiens c'est moins classe
mk-5 optic 2000
j'accueille nolwenn leroy
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
oh
wayne allwine barry vais en attendant on
va écouter la cartomancienne je suis
venu parce que je savais que j'allais
passer la nuit ici je suis habillé
directement fait très bien joué à l'om
s'est déclaré en février dernier dans
télé star pour le moment je me sens pas
prête à aller chez ardisson
voilà alors qu'est ce qui vous a fait
changer d'avis le mois de mars après
après vous avoir rencontré à voile et
voilà vous êtes d'origine à la maison
exactement et avoir passé quelques
moments avec laurent baffie
alors attention on a tous été pris vers
sa fin il regarde landes
non là on a chanté on a chanté
ah oui justement pour pour l'association
laurette fugain
alors je répète donc tous les tableaux
qui sont là seront bientôt sur un site
internet
vendu au profit de l'association
laurette fugain ceux qui n'ont pas
d'argent ont quand même des plaquettes
on veut donner également leurs
plaquettes ah oui voilà il faut
s'inscrire dans les centres alors au
sujet de la star qu'ils aient déclaré
plein de points négatifs mais c'est le
positif qui l'a emporté au final si je
devais recommencer je recommencerai oui
parce que parce que c'est une expérience
qui m'a permis de me faire entendre et
et voilà habitant en province tu
habitais vous parlons vichy voilà habité
nom jésus christ de mondeville et salue
les chiffres auxquels ils font ça elvire
ans et les jeunes pleins de retard comme
je suis en panique en auvergne
voilà donc on cède on salue la bretagne
l'auvergne
non mais sérieux c'est marrant parce que
vous avez habité à saint-yorre à vichy
mais evian c'est de la merde
j'habite toujours à sainte y habitent
alors donc oui il y avait cent mille
cassette qui ont été envoyés à 100
milles cassette
moi je me suis filmé dans la bouche
ouais c'est un miracle ce type c'est ça
tu as raison bon allez non mais très
lucide quand même après la star avait
déclaré c'est maintenant que je vais
avoir à galérer c'est maintenant que ça
va être décisif et le 4 mars 2003 après
un mois de deux studios faisait sortir
votre premier album
[Musique]
voilà donc ça c'était le premier album
avec kc je n'ai vendu 500 milles mais
gérer dit c'est le deuxième album qui
sera décisif hélas s'ensuit un long
silence discographique mais aussi
médiatique
vous avez décidé de disparaître un
silence radio pendant plusieurs mois
c'est pas vraiment un silence radio
c'est qu'on m'a énormément vu pendant
une très courte période à cause du monde
bien sûr de l'émission à laquelle j'ai
participé ont été extrêmement médiatisé
puis d'un coup je me suis juste enfermé
en studio j'ai travaillé sur mes textes
et toutes ces périodes de création là
forcément c'est difficilement associable
avec avec une exposition médiatique et
puis j'ai fait silence pour qu'on
entende le vote il ya des gens qui
étaient revenus charrette malaquais
sergent qui dira qu est ce qui va se
passer ça l'était raisons tirées en même
temps qu'ils baissent un peu la culture
a rappelé jean bon moyen terme la coupe
et la clim
un petit peu d'air mais non ça va mais
moi je suis habillé ses charges et
dimanche oui c'est vrai non non mais on
est un peu 0 savait pas si con amiens
nous en recueillir ses cheveux c'est
lors de son audition secours ouais bah
ouais raison en noir ça c'est très
gentil ça me fait plaisir
bah oui donc sinon c'est en fait pour
travailler puis mieux faire entendre
votre voix quand vous quand vous
reviendrez c'est ce qui s'est passé vous
avez travaillé sur un deuxième album
donc avec laurent voulzy
alors évidemment avec laurent voulzy
c'est long ça le problème de laurent
gaudé c'est pas tellement pour écrire
des mélodies d'ailleurs insurgé après on
sait même pas un problème c'est vrai que
aujourd'hui les albums s'enchaînent très
rapidement et forcément aussi lorsqu'on
est seulement interprète on va chercher
des chansons comme c'est un peu partout
et ça a tendance à aller plus vite mais
lorsqu'on écrit lorsqu'on concret ça ça
prend plus de temps c'est artisanal est
vrai que laurent il écrit et compose
extrêmement vite mais lui c'est plus la
réalisation du temps j'apprends du temps
un ouais alors cette absence des médias
a quand même été assez mal interprété
par par certains par vos détracteurs tu
vas encore lui revient toujours
ouais on m'a dit que vous étiez fini on
m'a dit qu'il y en a qui m'ont dit
qu'elle n'est pas finie mois
non mais c'est vrai que le véritable
métier d'un chanteur d'un artiste c'est
de composer créé en studio puis ensuite
de présenter ses chansons sur scène
bien sûr il ya la télé compte aussi mais
c'est vrai que c'est pas ce qui compte
le plus tu entends francis lalanne faire
des chansons
alors là donc pendant ce temps là vous
avez bâti les les fondations qui
manquait à votre carrière donc vous avez
pris le temps de faire un album qui vous
ressemble un album s'appelle histoire
naturelle au pluriel et deux enfants ils
sont grandes
c'est sorti en décembre dernier et il ya
un premier single qui a fait un carton
déjà
oh
[Applaudissements]
ça c'est une chanson j'ai cosigné avec
l'ordre
et 6 ans les enfants
[Applaudissements]
et maintenant et maintenant via le
deuxième single de l'album histoire
naturelle qui s'appelle aussi histoire
naturelle
[Musique]
voilà il sera naturel extrait de
l'histoire naturelle nous
sylvain
le web alors maintenant
[Applaudissements]
et
on n'a pas vu ça depuis maurice truander
les applaudit grossistes vous avez gardé
votre caméra c'est le cas le rouge vous
allez dire magnéto serge attention and
on n'a pas c'est bon t'es prêt magnéto
serge
[Musique]
le champ
le soir
[Musique]
ce soir là dessus c'est le mercure est
là
messieurs
[Applaudissements]
la loi ne leur en tournée dans toute la
france et le 9 et 10 octobre à l'olympia
cette salle de l'olympia ou lors de
votre première performance vous avez
rencontré laurent voulzy le rang avec
qui j'avais chanté indus auparavant mais
qu'est venu me voir ce soir là il m'a
proposé de deux ensembles ont travaillé
vous êtes devenu s'amuse
je pense qu'effectivement le rand a
écrit pour très peu de personnes dans sa
carrière et je crois qu'il a besoin
d'être inspiré d'une manière ou d'une
autre pour pour écrire des chansons pour
quelqu'un nous donc c'est une relation
enfin sincèrement ces mois-là d'amour
platonique d'un mètre dans une élève à
son maître à m voilà c'est énorme mais
c'est vrai qu'on a beaucoup chanté sur
cette histoire et c'est en fait pas du
tout c'était un amour complètement
platonique j'ai profité de la télévision
pour le dit oui dans les gens profitent
pour le dit pas certain que pour la
femme de laurence oui en plus aucun
souci
non non non mais c'est en tout cas je
suis privilégié d'avoir pu apprendre à
ses côtés pendant tous ces mois passés
en studio profession que tu te
connaissais loi c'est par costa 19 1 me
non mais c'est vrai que comme vous avait
personne dans votre vie on a toujours
tendance à vous attribuer des as ça
s'est arrangé la haye
ah oui asselah mieux alors non parce
qu'à un moment elle même dit vous étiez
lesbienne mais vous le savez en fait la
nation prisme la maladie à un moment on
a dit il ya très longtemps parce que ma
meilleure amie à l'époque couche avec
moi au lait au château et non stacké été
était lesbienne donc tout le monde en a
conclu et d'ailleurs je sais assez va de
honte honte incroyable 20 je dire qu'on
peut être même errani toujours
aujourd'hui et c'est ce qui est vrai
alors nolwenn qu'est ce qui est vrai et
ce qui est pas vrai c'est plus simple ce
qui est pas vrai c'est voulzy et
lesbiennes il est lesbienne
nolwenn n'avait jamais été très branché
part ça vous a déclaré que quand vous
étiez plus jeune vous préfériez passer
vos week-ends à jouer de la musique
plutôt que de vous ennuyer avec un mec
quand j'étais plus jeune mais plus
jeunes n'ont effectivement mais oui
parce que j'étais au collège au lycée à
la fac toute la semaine effectivement le
peu de temps loisirs dont je disposais
jeu consacré à la musique donc mais bon
je me suis pas sûr non mais je me suis
rattrapé après aujourd'hui tout va bien
tout va bien vous fumez pas vous buvez
pas j'aimais pas les boîtes ou sinon
c'est pas que j'aime pas c'est que j'ai
pas vraiment l'occasion mais ouais non
jour non qui vous plaît c'est le cheval
en fait ouais c'est comme ça qu'on s'est
connus ben dis donc tu te vantes
oui je veux bien mais doit le poney et
encore avec le mieux en astarac vous
avez acheté un marocain noir s'appelle
aberkane bombarder les papiers ou pas
barbe mannequin et que tu perds je suis
votre cousine en normandie qui se passe
chez moi en fait on est voisins avec
nolwenn way en se croisant le train d'un
animateur et voilà
[Musique]
nolwenn des teen star académicienne est
devenu une star en faire une table star
est-ce que depuis que vous êtes star
c'est plus facile avec les garçons non
parce que justement j'ai c'est d'être
avec des gens qui savent pas vraiment
faim pas qu'ils savent pas ce que je
fais mais qui connaissent pas vraiment
mon métier phare qui sont peut-être pas
d'ici quoi ou qui n'aiment pas la
musique voilà qui n'aiment pas la fin
est-ce que depuis que vous êtes star
vous payez encore vos vêtements
ah oui ah oui le 2big vous êtes ça au
fait de doigt d'honneur aux paparazzi
non parce que j'ai jamais l'occasion de
les voir malheureusement si je les
voyais je pourrais le faire mais c'est
toujours par surprise voilà
toi tu fais des tu le vois pas est-ce
que depuis vous êtes sort vous avez viré
tous vos anciens amis
non au contraire j'ai très peu de
nouveaux amis en fait j'ai presque que
des anciens amis donc ce soit mes amis
de deux collèges de lycées et tous mes
amis des etats-unis
ce que j'ai vécu un an un an aux états
unis donc j'ai tous les amis étudiants
en échange
et puis mes amis américains maintenant
vous avez un nouvel ami moi et voilà une
vidéo en échange aussi est-ce que depuis
que cette star vous casser tout dans les
chambres d'hôtel en fait le genre de
chambres d'hôtels dans les cadets
descend pendant les tournées il n'y a
pas grand chose a cassé dans les
chambres gros que je connais pas grand
jeu et toi tu casse tout un champ motel
[Musique]
vous réagissez comme ans quand on vous
fait prendre l'avion en deuxième place
je réagis bien parce que je les prie à
il ya une semaine en 2e classe l'avion
et je vais super bien ça va ouais ouais
ouais les petites jambes en même temps
oui j'ai des petites jambes et puis oui
mais pas vraiment une différence entre
la business c'est la classe fait gaffe
en tête à l'essence de vedettes comme si
un cas pour lequel tom enders
est-ce que depuis que cette soirée des
prix sur la drogue ou maintenant j'ai
jamais fumé non mais c'est sans âge je
vous jure c'est mal barré
un pas besoin de boire ou de fumer je
m'amuse très bien tout seul
est ce que le budget spurs et déjà exigé
une table dans un restaurant complet
exigé non dit mon nom en appelant une
fois il y a
il ya justement juste après le concert
pour la fugue un gt dîner avec maurane
et j'ai appelé un restaurant et j'ai dit
qu'on était toutes les deux pour avoir
une table c'était tomates d'europe et
s'organiser quand un fan vous reconnaît
dans la rue vous montez les vitres de la
voiture en vitesse
thierry il ya des murs tombent
maintenant c'est moi
rattrapé par ma nage c'est l'époque des
tracteurs massey ferguson plantes
l'époque des uva 4 4 chevaux dans ton
film excellent elle est belle est ce que
maintenant vous êtes sa pensée que les
critiques sont tous des cons et surtout
ceux de libé je sais pas si mon album
j'ai des chroniques et dans libé mais
semble pas mais récemment j'ai trouvé
j'ai eu un truc très sympa sur moine en
rock n folk question c'est quand même
énorme
c'est bien c'est très contente dans
l'hérault mais sincèrement un gps que
maintenant vous êtes star vous refusez
données dans des soirées où il n'ya pas
de cadeaux offerts je vais pas dans les
soirées et pas surtout celles où il ya
les cadeaux offerts laura tuiles votre
nom et je n'ai pu y aller non j'ai
jamais pu rencontrer beigbeder dans une
forêt quartier l'aurait pas fait a
espéré quartier c'est peut-être sympa
est-ce que vous avez déjà zappé michel
drucker qui essayez de vous joindre
ah non jamais d'ailleurs j'ai participé
récemment à plusieurs émissions et
michel drucker et gt1
j'étais ravi c'est vrai kebede
énormément est ce que maintenant vous
êtes star vous attaquer systématiquement
quand on parle de vous dans voici
oui moi systématiquement est ce que
maintenant vous êtes star vous imposer
qu'on parle pas de certaines choses dans
les interviews non j'avoue the rien je
n'impose rien j'en parle pas tu voudrais
qu'on parle pas de quoi ce soir
particulièrement bas vous justement vous
en avez pas parlé encore non vous n'avez
pas demandé de noël je trouve que c'est
mieux de pas en parler voilà marwijk
non mais ce soir sort des dents que
celle c'est très sympa peux pas en
parler bien que je ça me dérange pas
forcément d'en parler mais il ya des
histoires qui qui valent pas la peine
qu'on en parle en fait je crois qu'il
faut le dire quand même parce que la
mairie est bien sinon les
téléspectateurs n'ont pas compris les
mots tout mon enfance mon on a beaucoup
parlé lorsque je suis sorti
effectivement
été révélée pas c'est vrai que là lui
c'est un peu partout et je crois que
j'ai pas envie de tout cas de ne pas lui
faire cet honneur mais c'est une
histoire qui n'est pas forcément
extrêmement intéressantes et avec tout
mon proc
allez donc voilà donc on en a parlé when
a man
non
[Musique]
deux trois quarts
oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cartomancienne tu l'avais livre va
deviner la carte vous devinez quoi
vous devez vous racontez votre dernière
nuit d'amour au dans le box
c'était alors je vais juste dire c'était
y'a pas longtemps mais c'était pas en
france c'était plutôt en amérique du
nord vers new york par la non côte ouest
1 c'est là où tu étais partir pour les
échanges pour les échanges tandis que la
revue dingo cg mer que oui mesdames
messieurs
dany boon
[Musique]
quel succès c'est dingue je savais pas
que l'union était la voix la carrière de
miu miu ça va ça n'a pas empêché de
faire une carrière à ses dépens je
connais un peu ou prou cas pas fait
carrière carrière ça va et il ya elle ça
va bien et là elle va bien elle va très
bien on va lui demander
on appelle y est yaël
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors un invité mystère il va poser des
questions et on répond par oui pardon de
l'autre devinez qui c'est est ce que
brad
je me cachais balles apparemment bon ce
qu'on va faire si on va égaliser un peu
et on va désépaissir on va retirer des
volumes florence on vous raconte il a
également battu 8 ya du boulot ce soir
un boulot et j'avais une question on est
sur quelle chaîne c'est toujours le cas
on est sur l'a2 encore toujours là de
plus j'aurai deux
ça
ça va bien tout est superbe et très très
bien on sent ça l'a bien fait pour
l'heure s'il s'était converti au
judaïsme pour vous mais il a changé
bouddhisme ou alors tu restes de boutoir
nantes et asilah telles observations le
sens certaines activités visent un
incroyable la vie tu le vis et ça c'est
quoi une fiche les titres nba bongani
vous êtes ici pour un film vous êtes ici
braves avec ma femme avec votre charme
c'est normal tellement mignonne c'est
vrai vous êtes ici pour un film dont
vous êtes scénariste réalisateur co
producteur acteur si ça se plante ne va
pas demander l'appui
à qui la faute sur les conseils de
laurent baffie sur les conseils avisés
alors je puisse appeler la maison du
bonheur c'est l'adaptation de votre
pièce la vie de chantier
le titre a été choisi par yaël qui ne
connaissait pas la chanson de francis
lalanne sinon vous auriez pas pris 6
litres non
non non elle seule non un g1 comme la
chanson we et francis lalanne m'a fait
france yann le supporter l'équipe de
france l'énervent ya elle était inscrite
au générique du film mais toujours eu et
a fait tonner elle a travaillé elle a
travaillé sur le film vous avez déclaré
elle a été mon miroir sur toutes les
phases de l'écriture elle a visionné les
rushs elle a suivi de montage tout ça en
s'occupant du mouflet en plus non ils
agissent et il n' est d'ailleurs le même
jour que ya elle est née le même jour à
2h10 et les juifs c'est pour un gâteau
période c'est l'économie c'est ni c'est
marrant dany sérieusement à quel point
les femmes de votre vie ont toujours été
mêlé à votre travail
comment ça se fait mais j'ai beaucoup
travaillé tirer jolie et ouais on a très
bon on n'a pas vécu tellement longtemps
ensemble
non on s'est pas marié déjà mme là on
n'a pas réussi à avoir d'enfants
et voilà nommé judith godrèche déjà été
très impliquée dans votre vie
professionnelle
oui c'est vrai c'est vrai ce métier les
cta que vous et s'est assise à côté de
moi pour voir qu'en juillet 6 juillet
c'est vrai dans les très prochains
non mais pourquoi vous vous êtes si
impliqué avec vos femmes dans le travail
je sais pas impliqué avec mes femmes
c'est plus sympa il s'est pas d'abord
spanish airs de femme c'est une histoire
de rencontre donc il se trouve que
effectivement yaël que j'ai donc enlevé
de suisse puisqu'elle et les suissesses
voilà la quitter son travail il se
trouve qu'elle a qu'elle a des dons pas
mal de dons et voilà et puis elle est on
travaille ensemble
effectivement elle a fait donc sur la
pièce elle a la cote chez gym soie laine
pour l'accent portugais
elle a fait les chorégraphies ce café de
la danse à la fait toutes les grandes
chorégraphies de mon spectacle à chanter
sur des chansons de mon spectacle à la
maison du bonheur donc de dany boon avec
michèle laroque daniel prévost zinedine
soualem
laurent gamelon line renaud et et vous
bien sûr sortie le 7 juin
alors le pitch c'est un mari radin qui
décide d'être enfin généreuse va bien
les cheveux bas alors le pitch donc
c'est l'histoire d'un à marie radin qui
décide d'être enfin généreux avec sa
femme en lui offrant une maison de
campagne
mais pour faire des économies il fait
confiance à un agent immobilier douteux
qui lui proposent des ouvriers fois
revoilà et la surprise se transforme en
cauchemar et se termine en pur des liens
vraiment c'est une catastrophe
c'est très drôle merci ouais on va voir
à quoi ça ressemble j'ai regardé votre
caméra c'est le cal rouge et vous il ya
elle vous regardez celle qu'elle a donc
on va le faire pour la première fois un
lancement croisés si la voix n'a pas
qu'on fait ça c'est un lancement
strabisme vakili magnéto l'autre qui dit
serge voilà vous dites magnéto et vous
vous dites serge attendu inverse n'ont
pas changé de cette édition
cette édition est déjà assez compliqué
comme ça rien à faire le rang magnéto
vous et vous vous dites c'est attention
on va s'arrêter juste quand les gens
vont commencer à rouler méchant 2,3 à
temps comme vous le faites si vous êtes
prêts bien sûr
on est d'accord là dessus bien sûr
normal tu sois prêt attention vous êtes
prêts attention initial tu dises faire
le poids attention un deux trois taux
l'époque tommy avec les relevés de temps
très bon bah non dans 20 minutes c'est
demi tarif
c'est pas grave c'est ma femme parce que
je suis à la bourre il rappellera et pas
comme ça avant tu es devenu radin radars
moins radins oui mais bonjour excusez
moi je veux juste un enseignement que ça
moi une maison en vitrine
elle est vendue non je plaisante je te
rappelle cela dit quelle heure 11h10
sais pas
[Musique]
alors ça a à peine deux minutes de paris
enfin roland bien bien regardez moi
cette véranda comme ses lumineuses j'en
ai mal aux yeux par kalou 15 15 mais
faut qu'on a fait une visite surtout pas
leur est faite faites-lui la surprise ya
quatre ans qui va devoir qui vous a
autorisé à visiter des maisons pendant
vos heures de bureau je pensais pas
qu'il arrive quatre gérer il faut qu'on
augmente d'insultés pour faire
d'étranges surtout pas ou alors mon lot
de mamie être pire a dit eh bien comme
ça qu'est ce que vous voulez comme
travaux mais vous n'avez pas un éclat à
c'est que quand on est perdu qu'on a
besoin de plans nous a dit qu'il fallait
qu'on profite de la vie alors j'ai
acheté une voiture c'est 30 euros pour
allociné interdit bancaire oui interdits
bancaires
plus tard tu me le piquer qui est tombée
des travaux coûtent beaucoup plus cher
que prévu expliquez-moi pourquoi zappant
là partout qu'est-ce qui par là partout
mais là les câbles un partout la balle
est justement à propos des cas bon voila
vous demandez vous les voulez cacher
dans un faux plafond ou comme ça toute
apparence et prenez votre meilleure
équipe mais mais mais c'est la meilleure
on essayait de cacher je vais vous
mettre en arrêt maladie
[Musique]
on n'a jamais déménagé aujourd'hui la
déménager ça ça va aller sans ménager
plus difficile
j'ai trouvé les gaz sortie le 16
[Applaudissements]
ces gars là je suis venu avec lui aussi
intervenir à comines
le chien
messieurs comment ça va bien il est prêt
pour la promo l'a pas mal
amal a pas marre de répéter que là on va
répéter un peu la promo au départ dany
boon cette histoire de travaux est
inspiré d'une histoire vécue
oui l'histoire des moulures par exemple
hélas la baguette entre autres c'était
un appartement genre haussmannien la
jolie avec des belles moulures et
l'architecte voit une baguette de
téléphone en plastique et voilà il dit
il il prend un de ces gars et il dit tu
me vois tu m'enlèves l'a1 finissent par
lasser
c'est dur non et le gars niveau ça
j'aurais dû me méfier le fait bien
et puis voilà et donc on part voir le
truc parler les plans les machins trucs
et on revient à un quart d'heure après
il avait enlevé toutes les moulures sur
ce match
y a s'ils croyaient que la baguette
était plus moderne en pastique donc il
se disait ça faut que ça reste elle est
bien il avait fait un petit à un ami il
avait fait un petit avec le on aurait
dit qu'il allait faire un petit feu de
camp et j'ai dit les moulures les
moulures ça il m'a dit ah ça va vous
frappez pas je voulais remettre et il
les a remis un peu de travers il ya
aussi la peinture dans le sanitaire la
peinture dans le sanitaire c'est quand
il a émis la peinture d'un sanitaire ça
à la bouche et le sanitaire
oui ça c'est récent ça bah oui c'est le
fait on va voir si c'est ça c'est récent
c'est il ya trois semaines à la campagne
le nom il avait vidé
oui de la peinture qui a séché dans un
coup de l'évacuation de toilette et donc
quelqu'un nous inviter à tirer la chasse
d'eau et au lieu de la facture il a fait
le dos l'autre côté et on était dans
l'embarras et ça a fait le long des murs
comme ça et donc non ils ont été réussis
ont dû tout casser et ont pour refaire
les coudes tous les coudes vous êtes
angoissé dany boon oui ça c'est la
question
une question qu'on va te poser beaucoup
dans la promotion vous êtes un angoissé
dany boon est ce que vous étiez vous
accédez à la caméra non j'étais pas gt
non j'étais ça allait non j'étais pas
trop angoissé non j'ai beau j'ai
beaucoup travaillé sur le film en
préparation justement pour pour pas
l'être dany boon vous préférez devant ou
derrière
peut-être un peu posé la question est ce
que tu veux référence est beaucoup plus
confortable d'être devant oui que
derrière votre passé de storyboarder et
photographes vous a aidé c'est tout à
fait vrai dirigé mois que vous êtes bien
renseigné
je ne comprends pas pourquoi vous fait
licencier de le france de lagardère
votre émission et je trouve ça
complètement quand
oui j'étais dessinateur et gt2 et
storyboarder donc effectivement j'ai
appris à découper une histoire en plan
qu est ce qu on pense évidemment
d'autres il a beaucoup bossé sur ce
sujet il a beaucoup bossé sur ce faire
il a bossé de groupe c de 5 heures du
matin à minuit tu te regarde oui c'est
un super arrêt dont j'avais énormément
là on prépare la promo là il y avait un
truc super drôle sur le tournage je peux
raconter une anecdote eu ce que tu veux
tu es en escrime pour une de ses deux
leaders de béziers au tir et patrick si
tu m'entends
s il est encore au moins une année
c'est vrai que c'était drôle la maison
qu'on détruit qu'on a remis en état
d'ailleurs pas avec la même équipe la
maison qu'on a des trucs se trouve à
maisons laffitte et donc au début on n'a
pas eu les autorisations de tournage
s'est scindé le député-maire de
maisons-laffitte s'appelle jacques
chaque milliard pour la non pendant ce
billet revient mais bien hard way
voilà mon bref il nous donne pas les
autorisations et grâce à claude berri on
les obtient il nous dit il est dit et il
fait à la production il dit voilà je
veux rencontrer dany boon en tournée
pendant un mois la ben ali je veux
rencontrer d'un niveau de jeu dit non
maintenant je travaille j'ai pas le
temps ça ça m'intéresse pas et puis non
non non non et la production de 10
insiste en disant ça serait mieux qu'ils
viennent parce qu'il a finalement
accepté qu'on tourne dans sa ville c'est
vrai c'est sympa et puis voilà il n'a
qu'à venir pendant l'heure du déjeuner
ça dure une heure et après voilà tu
déjeunes avec l'hymne il est très
sympathique et items beaucoup bon je dis
d'accord donc il arrive juste en train
de travailler
g bonjour monsieur myard voilà je
termine puis non je dis voilà on est
pause déjeuner on va à la cantine est
sur le chemin de la cantine il se tourne
vers moi puis me fait vous vous faites
quoi sur le sur le film j'ai dit mais je
suis acteur j'ai écrit tout ça et je
réalise il me dit vous vous produisez
aussi le jeu produit enfin en
coproduction mais comme comme moteur
mais mais oui pourquoi il me dit vous
êtes claude berri je te jure que c'est
vrai en fait non je suis élu semoun
vous devez aller je le dis je suis elie
semoun il me fait homme et oui mais oui
pardon il y excusez moi eh bien il me
dit ça va pas fort en ce moment avec
dieudonné
je dis oui on a séparé on a un peu des
soucis veut faire de la politique un
comme vous c'est pas facile là c'est sûr
et on marchande en une part je vous
parle à elie semoun depuis un mois il
fait mais il est où dany boon évident
mais je vous le présenter et je vois
laurent gamelon donc qui fait de m voilà
qui est là où je fais dany député maire
jacques meyer qui veut te derniers jours
jeudi discrètement que je suis allé chez
moune qu'il est dany boon ça et il fait
un homonyme ou nous je vous adore depuis
longtemps bravo pour tout ce que vous
faites il lui dit à lui sur ce je pense
à zinedine soualem qui est dans le film
et je vais vous connaissez smaïn
on s'est retrouvés à table avec une
grande partie du show business français
et personne ne correspondait la bonne
personne il y avait juste à sa
secrétaire que vers 6 à côté de moi qui
tu vois qui était morte de trouille qui
me disait dans l'oreille
bon dominique servent à la promo nom va
bien nager pas surveillée non non est ce
qu'on pourrait dire de plus sur le
prince britannique qui est toujours sous
tranquillisants non je suis rassuré mais
ils reviennent kahn assure dominique
appel car c'est elle moi je pars contre
suis inquiet pour l'avenir havrais
qu'est ce qu'on va devenir m'arrive
c'est bien moi
quand c'est pas grave mais bien nos fils
nos spectacles qu'est ce qu'on va faire
si on va tous se donner la mort
alors dany vous êtes quand même un
acteur maintenant assez reconnus parce
que dans joyeux noël et une formidable
j'ai été nommé aux césar ensuite j'ai eu
la doublure de webber avec gad elmaleh
bientôt mon meilleur ami de patrice
leconte avec daniel auteuil ça ça
commence à exister un oui oui c'est
d'ailleurs la chance de tourner avec eux
avec patrice leconte est de donner la
réplique à daniel auteuil pendant trois
mois c'était s'était formée avant un
très beau rôle en plus un très très beau
film je les jambes en ciel bas et vie
direct il n'est pas bon mais je crois
que il n'y a plus qu'une chose à faire
maintenant que vous êtes un grand acteur
dany boon c'est une interview alain
delon
pensez vous que le public aime dany boon
dany boon pense que le public aime dany
boon mais mais mais pas autant que dany
boon ne s'aiment et dany boon et le jour
où le public chemra autant que dany boon
sem
le public sera ce que c'est qu'être dany
boon nous pensez vous de dany boon
l'homme dany boon pense que les femmes
ont beaucoup de chance que dany boon
soit un homme pour vous dany boon est
synonyme de quoi franchement je suis
dany boon est très déçue que thierry
ardisson pose cette question pensez vous
que dany boon sur le plus grands
comédiens français dany boon est un
grand comédien c'est vrai renesas pas
français et les ch'timis ah oui vous
pensez que dany boon peut tout jouer
dany boon ne pourra jamais jouer dany
boon c'est beaucoup trop durs car il
faut être dany boon et en même temps
être dany boon et jose dany boon c'est
impossible
dany boon a peut être moins défoncés
est-ce que vous pensez que dany boon
laissera une trace dans le cinéma
français une trace de pneu oui est ce
que dany boon espère avoir bientôt une
rue à son nom
mais dany boon des attire ardisson
rentrer dany boon dans ton gps et tu
verras est ce que dany boon est lui
aussi une star au japon
dany boon effectivement était au japon
récemment avec un certain alain delon et
les japonais disait tu veux dire
qui est cet homme à côté de dany boon
avant
ça sera le 7 juin c'est avec dany
et michèle laroque
il
t
mais comme moi
et deux trois quarts
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
carte conseil d'ami c'est quoi c'est
parce que c'est que vous devez donner un
conseil à maurice barthélémy pour lui
expliquer comment faire avec judith
godrèche concept car vraiment elle est
très concept cars va prendre une autre
mais il sait très bien faire j'avais
très très bien ah oui voila se passe
bien mais très très bien et voilà il
monfils nouvelle il adore d'ailleurs
c'est un super beau père il a fait un
très bon film en plus papa ouais karch
si vous donnez nous chanter les corons
de pierre bachelet en pleurant en
pleurant tu connais les corps oui bien
sûr bienvenue à senna bastien qu'elle
allait faire au nom chez tous les coraux
les hommes des videurs de fonds
merci
j'adore le sait
j'accueille renaud revel
[Musique]
bonsoir êtes rédacteur en chef à
l'express vous publiez avec une autre
journaliste de l'express qui s'appelle
laurence debril un document intitulé
people
le grand déballage chez michel lafon
alors d'abord qu'est-ce qu'un people
mais beaucoup j'en attends que j'ai
l'impression c'est quelqu'un de connu en
vérité vous en êtes aussi un suivi pour
le moins aussi un mois je suis un
mariole scénarios les plus folles
alors dans le prologue de votre pays
vous décrivez la reine marie-antoinette
comme la première people et c'est vrai
que c'est la première star à avoir fait
l'objet d'une d'une traque médiatique
oui parce que sa vie privée a été gâté
et pied décortiqué traquer qu'à l'époque
effectivement on allait tous les matins
acheter de damparis des billets qui
étaient manuscrits qu est l élite et
quelques centaines d'exemplaires sur
laquelle figuraient les détails de la
vie privée une agente honnête et
sexuelles conjugales domestique
oui il y avait des nouvelles du dû me
royal et vous dites dans votre livre ce
serait absolument impensable aujourd'hui
qu'on donne au sujet de sophie marceau
je crois que c'est l'exemple que vous
prenez qu'on disait au sujet de
marie-antoinette madison de chant
respecter affectant la couche entre
guillemets notre chaque matin et on en
faisait un détail effectivement quitté
manuscrits ensuite est distribué dans
paris quelques heures après ça a été les
premiers magazines de l'époque en vérité
oui c'est la première finalement avoir
été victime du commerce du ragot de lui
alors vous êtes à quai le bouquin par un
événement considérable
c'est la fameuse affaire cécilia sarkozy
donc c'est la première fois dit vous en
france que la vie privée d'un homme
politique de premier plan et jeté en
pâture aux médias en août 2005 paris
match publie des photos de cécilia
sarkozy et richard attias ce à new york
et vous préciser que c'est la deuxième
meilleure vente de l'année 2005 après la
mort du peuple ne mendie pas dans paris
match mais ça pour vous c'est quelque
chose qu'on n'avait pas vu son enfant
depuis 40 ans il ya 40 ans on se
souvient que même que le couple pompidou
avait fait l'objet à l'époque
ouais mais rumeurs nauséabondes que la
presse d'extrême droite à une reprise
largement d'ailleurs est ce la première
fois que la vie privée d'une politique
est traqué à ce point là c'est vraiment
eu six mois de traque effectivement il
sarkozy sa vie privée quand même dessus
ont été pillés épiée traquée manière
assez assez assez étonnante et ça a été
une grande première effectivement un
première alors qu'on sait s'il revient
en janvier 2006
rtl annonçait un communiqué ce qui est
absolument incroyable
pourquoi et en fait les retrouvailles
entre cécilia sarkozy et nicolas sarkozy
donne lieu à un numéro spécial de vsd
neuvième des cafés 3,4 cover de match
qu'on a fait quelques unes également la
presse people effectivement a fait ses
choux gras ça et il ya eu en vérité de
la 3 millions d'exemplaires qui sont
vendus sur cette affaire-là
donc ce que vous décrivez en tout cas
car dans votre bouquin c'est cette
peopolisation du politique et garonne et
chirac par exemple qui va parler de sa
fille anorexique laurence chez fogiel ce
qui est absolument impensable quoi
c'était impensable ces dix ou quinze ans
aujourd'hui au plus aucun tabou et
aucune limite plus qu'une pile heure
je crois que chacun y va on l'a vu ces
jours ci avec le couple strauss kahn
sinclair qui a la foi dans paris match
sur tf1 qui jusqu'ici n'avait jamais mis
sa vie privée quand tout cas de cette
manière là sur la table et qui sont plus
aucune pudeur le fait aujourd'hui
c'était impensable encore une fois il ya
dix ou quinze un jack lang qui annonce
sa candidature à la candidature dans
voici son récit
c'est incroyable mais c'est vrai quand
tu lis un bouquin c'est assez assez
assez passé totalement inaperçu mais
c'est vrai que lang a été le premier
homme politique français il a fait les
démarches c'est une manière très
ostensible il a annoncé effectivement sa
connaissance dans voici
là il ya trois ans gars là sont proches
de dans playboy de lui alors ça marche
très très bien à la presse people ces
trois millions d'exemplaires par semaine
ces 12 millions d'hectares wifi
personnes et wallace + 50 % 15 ans il ya
des projets de presse en préparation il
ya deux jours nous qui vont sortir au
bout de septembre donc c'est un marché
exponentiel exponentielle personnes s'y
attendait quand closer est sorti en 2005
sur le marché tout le monde a souri ça a
été un boom faburel sept cent mille
exemplaires au moment de la faire perdre
nos acquis et rappelez-vous alors même
la presse non pipoles 6 mai le magazine
pour lequel vous vous travaillez
l'express fait sa couverture sur la
séropositivité de charlotte valandrey
c'est quand même assez ça nous a surpris
à l'époque mais on l'avait fait je pense
beaucoup d'unités de
et de pudeur aussi parce que le pape y
était joliment écrit mais ça a été un
succès c'est un succès et c'est vrai que
l'on peut difficilement passer à côté de
l'histoire comme celle là aussi pourquoi
l'express on appris aujourd'hui alors
qu'effectivement les français les gens
adorent ça pour peu qu'on le fasse
encore une fois dans la dignité et avec
un peu de sobriété un peu d'écriture
pourquoi pas alors vous raconter la
collusion entre les pipoles et la presse
people c'est très intéressant il ya ceux
qui réécrivent leur interview alors à
gianni par exemple réécrit ses
interviews arrivé en tout cas main sur
ta politique le fond ou s'il est arrivé
tu réécris des interviews nommage les
jeux les recopie avec un papier calque
toi tu ne vis pas moi non plus je dis
pas et toi tu réécris des interviews
parfois j'aurais aimé avoir l'occasion
de le faire non c'est la liberté de la
presse on peut pas réécrire ses
interviews maintenant c'est vrai que
souvent ils proposent sont sortis du
contexte et souvent on aimerait pouvoir
le faire souvent les journalistes
réécrire une interview parce qu'ils
essayent de compiler toutes les infos
ils font les phrases qu'on peut rien à
voir exactement qui sont vidés de sens
il ya ceux qui réécrivent des interviews
effectivement comme adjani dites-vous et
puis il ya ceux qui changent
complètement ce qu'ils ont dit s'ils
représentent sarkozy un jour on lui fit
l'interview il dit moi j'en ai rien à
[ __ ] du psg je regarde pas les
émissions de variétés à la télé
après ils se rendent compte que c'est
quand même pas terrible donc qui corrige
l'interview il dit j'adore le psg et
puis je regarde toutes les émissions de
s'arrêter à la télé c'est extraordinaire
de nous inviter des propos qui les
conseillers ont dit mais c'est pas
possible
il leur écrit effectivement la réponse
c'est incroyable il ya bruel aussi dit
vous qui êtes allés au montage de
fréquences tard oui mais brûle quelqu'un
qui fait très attention à la fois son
image communication il vérifie tout
d'ailleurs c'est plutôt une qualité
dans le détail y compris dans les photos
de lui qui sont commis dans la presse
people dans paris match ou ailleurs
c'est lui-même qui choisit les photos il
voit dans l'action il suit la mise en
page c'est quelqu'un d'extrêmement mais
titulaire sa vie privée mais est-ce que
la sortie ça c'est petit spa
complètement le personnage sans doute
mais en même temps ça me protège parce
que c'est vrai qu'il fait partie des
gens que même qui de tout temps ont
jamais été écornée par la presse people
parce que comme johnny hallyday
d'ailleurs qu'ils ont toujours fait très
attention à leur image depuis 30 ou 40
ans pour johnny en tout cas et leur
style assez que leur image est intacte
et qu'ils ont toujours fait très
attention
ouais y'a janvier a permis à l'or lui
vous dites c'est terrible parce qu'en
fait il a été pris à partie par la
presse people quand tu l'histoire avec
sa femme histoire incroyable marquée
ouais il me dit qu'il était dans une
convention de toyota avec une voiture
siglée closer oui c'est un geste un
garçon qui était un peu d'hémiplégie
parce que il a fait tout et son
contraire dans sa vie il a attaqué la
presse people il ay là il a fait 45 ans
et en diffamation à la l'été dernier à
voix signal à vis des autres journaux
qu'il avait effectivement salma attaque
et il a eu raison de le faire
il parce que effectivement il a vécu cet
été une manière très difficile en
revanche c'est quelqu'un qui dans sa vie
a toujours négocié invendus a vendu
entre guillemets à la fois son image sa
vie privée avant et après
d'un côté effectivement il a beaucoup
attaqué la presse people et de l'autre
il en a vécu comme entraîneur j'aimerais
donc c'est une c'est une c'est une
ambiguïté celui les pas le seul dans ce
métier le virus mutant secteur
et puis il ya ceux comme johnny hallyday
avec qui a jamais de problème c'est un
miracle absolu à la guerre parce que ça
fait qu'ils sont quarante ans quand une
fois que ce garçon en vérité n'a jamais
été vraiment attaqué par la presse il
est respecté par ce métier ou très peu
cette règle a été bien sûr qu'il a été
un ange de 40 ans bien sûr on oublie
vite les choses
heureusement doute oui il ya une très
belle image d'une la presse quand même
le respecte en général en général quand
même s'il a de bonnes relations avec la
presse écrite
il a l'habitude en tout cas est parce qu
il la gère extrêmement bien je crois
qu'il est bien entouré il connaît bien
ce métier connaît bien les photographes
il connaît bien ces professions et je
crois que que tout ça finit par payer
que j'ai fait le compte il est quand
même assez barney s'est pendu mais vous
dites alors johnny s'est tu payes je
pose un la naissance d'adoption il le
fait le disque la wii est en tout cas
organise lit le fait avec beaucoup de
2,2 de sébazac aussi une pause pas
toutes les façons c'est d'être volé
ouais mon kiné autant poser que ça soit
contrôlée plutôt que voler que ses
membres s'esquisse à ses protégés tu le
voyais tout compris le fait dans toute
transparence tout le monde le sait
lui-même le revendiquer
il affiche et je crois que c'est là
c'est la bonne démarche oui ce que
j'allais dire c'est peut-être la
meilleure solution c'est absolument
ouais bah oui comme ça au moins tu es
c'est un peu faustien quoi comme la star
ac alors très intéressant aussi dans
votre bukavu dit qui alimentent la
presse pipole alors il ya d'abord les
pipots le même qui font passer des des
infos mais plutôt les mêmes ils soient
compris quand tout compris on vous
ressort de ce marché dont qui on joue
qui alimente beaucoup une très grande
part effectivement si on devait vaincre
envie de quitter sa femme par exemple
qui s'est photographiée et que sa
maîtresse comme ça c'est trop qui l'a
pas à lui annoncé quoi je suis passé
justement vous savez que c'est arrivé il
ya l'entourage les jantes ouvrages sont
réceptives monsieur ans et elle évite
par exemple que loana c'est sa propre
mère qui a vendu à paris match les
photos du bébé
oui parce que les familles sont souvent
effectivement très active un lui-même
elles doivent également les défendu à
solliciter ça mais ouais bien sûr elle
n'a pas fait de son entrepôt oui et puis
les gens fragiles qui sait elle
facilement puissante pas qu il ya
beaucoup d'argent en jeu à chaque fois
c'est souvent et souvent des gens des
fois des gens dans les milieux c'est
simple et c'est vrai que quand même le
mirage de ce miroir là quand même facile
et puis à les apporteurs d'affaires les
qui touchent des commissions plus évoqué
notamment le cas de star beaucoup ils
sont encore une fois les entourages les
entourages
et alors il ya la nouvelle hantise des
pipoles c'est les sna paradis des
portables ouais le portable
enfin c'est terrible ça c'est terrible
ce n'est jamais pareil de coke
kate moss quitta plus haut absolu oui
parce que c'est du niveau mois
danger absolu aujourd'hui n'importe qui
peut prendre une photo de n'importe qui
sera sur un trottoir le balancer sur
internet dans la foulée way où le vent
dans un journal ce qui a été proposé à
l'express à plusieurs reprises je me
souviens nous on nous a contacté un jour
c'est un garçon qui était à cannes
c'était un jeune garçon qui a un
portable
ils nous proposaient des photos de
cécilia sarkozy à l'époque ouais et on
les a pas acheté bien sûr mais ça c'est
très fréquent maintenant aujourd'hui les
journaux sont submergés de propositions
de jean total -2 d'un qu'ils vendent
effectivement tout tout à la fois sur le
net et dans la presse par ailleurs oui
mais j'étais restée pipoles alors parce
que maintenant on peut plus énervé dans
un aéroport le plus important c'est un
vrai bien vrai danger c'est que timité
des stars aujourd'hui qu'ils étaient peu
protégée va devenir un flou absolu
mouais bah oui ça va être terrible
alors il ya un truc quand même qui est
encore plus grave dans la fabrication de
la pipoleries là c'est ce qui s'est
passé sur la star ac 5 entre mode et
jérémy dire que vous dites maintenant
peu importe la véracité de ce qu'on
raconte c'est à dire que tout le monde
sait que c'est faux que c'est bidon que
c'est monté mais c'est pas grave
seule compte la satisfaction du plaisir
immédiat oui c'est le combino nage
absolue ouais c'est un métier qui fait
sur un coin de table on regarde plus la
seule chose qui importe c'est la photo
c'est une vague scène et leur est
entièrement général scénarisé il très
très compliqué de trouver la vérité dans
tout cela et puis voilà puis à l'argent
aussi que les procès rapporte aux pipots
l'un stéphanie de monaco vous dites
quand même 3 millions d'euros de
dommages et intérêts en 15 ans net
d'impôt si le russe est plus gros
pactole mais enfin elle en avait besoin
il ya des gens qui n'ont pas besoin
c'est moral ça finit bien
déjà fait des procès à des journaux toi
ah oui messieurs et alors je quand on a
été pris en photo il ya l'avocat on voit
un papier bleu pour prévenir qu'on sait
qu'on a été pris en photo et pour dire
ne ne publiez pas sinon il y aura procès
en général sa soeur il publie pas donc
on attend pas qu'ils publient et puis on
nous a proposé est plein de trucs mois
on m'a proposé nous a proposé d'acheter
notre mariage ça aurait largement
couvert les fruits c'est le cas chez les
champeaux me on a bu bout et de la
clairette de die et mais voilà on l'a on
l'a pas fait moi quand je me suis fait
attaquer sur l'autoroute
oh là là je m'en souviens de cette
histoire quelle horreur et bunge et
j'avais donc on avait neuf points de
suture fin j'étais menacé par ce que
j'ai récupéré mon chien dans les
voitures bref
ben on m'a appelé on dit bien c'est le
labrador qui gueule dans les loges
connaissez ce que les voitures pour un
con moi je m'étais fait attaquer par des
faux policiers qui m'ont arrêté sur la
bande d'arrêt d'urgence et elle est la
vraie police n'arrête pas sur la bande
d'arrêt d'urgence donc je savais pas que
la police en fait elle emmène jusqu'à
une aire de repos 1-1 voilà où une
station
donc je voulais faire passer le message
comme quoi fallait pas s'arrêter
donc j'ai fait un robin comment l
interview pour paris match mais sans
photo mais on m'a proposé de faire la
couverture de match de vsd de tous les
journaux avec ma gueule amoché quoi donc
je vois là je vais pas fait mais n'a pas
fait de procès s'ils n'ont jamais c'est
allé très loin quoi laisser prendre en
photo avec notre fils entre c'est pas
mal
ah ouais mais bon j'ai le papier bleu ça
marche bien je crois que les îles et
people sont très peu protégés finalement
et encore plus aujourd'hui avec avec les
portables et tout ça c'est pas très
sympa c'était sur l'essai pas moral pas
ce qu'ils vont dans les soirées sur
offrir des portables aux qataris
chroniqué par des portages de brest
[Applaudissements]
jamais bossé avec la presse 6 à 6,6 avec
voici un pas uniquement voici public est
là dedans ça va pas tarder oui mais en
tout cas ils s'en foutent là vous dites
dans votre book à renaud revel que les
procès par an pour voir si ça représente
2 % du chiffre d'affaires c'est très
original ça marche donc même limite us
où il rencontre aussi je crie et en même
temps il y avait paul qui font des
procès qui sont déboutés par exemple ou
poivre d'arvor
c'est arrivé mais carole bouquet pouvoir
vous en quelques uns parce qu'à force
dans celles effectivement les juges 6e
comment ça quand même attendre un peu le
nez il ya certaines juridictions qui
font très attention à ce qu'ils les
voient défilent à longueur d'année donc
au bout du moment où du 15e 20e procès
il dit stop
donc on regarde de plus près ouais donc
incertain effectivement certains clients
entre guillemets qui ne touche pas tous
les toits alors nous raconter évidemment
le pire c'est les people qui sont payés
pour l'épauler soirée c'est ce but de
très classique avec classique mais cher
quand même de 9 53 mille euros en
liquide dans les toilettes du majestic
les toilettes hommes ou femmes c'est
important pour la super fête devant les
flics à l'époque le littoral pour la
faire khelifa ouais bah oui c'est un
depardieu dans le par dieu c'est leur
lovelock qui avait été posé sur le sur
la tablette de son avion quoi
dans un vol paris nice depardieu 30000
euros et en afrique celle des toilettes
j'ai dû laisser 2 euros on assiste à une
théâtre au cra si oui parce que
aujourd'hui tout est spectacle tout et
people
chacun effectivement avance une image
pardonnez moi mais c'est pas vous qui
êtes encore du tout mais la moindre star
aujourd'hui gardé la star academy wire
devient une vedette en espace
un instant de quelques secondes quelques
minutes quelques quelques jours
extraordinaires dans votre bouquin quand
vous racontez par exemple que jennifer
lopez et ben affleck
ils ont pu se rapporter à la presse
pipole avec les papiers qui a eu sur eux
que ce qu'ils ont rapporté aux
producteurs du film d'amour trop bu
c'est quelque chose quand même
alors que les stars des années 50 il
avait une vie privée très caché un sens
avait rien de et il y avait une magie un
mystère et maintenant il faut qu'on vous
faut tout savoir c'est vrai ça c'est
juste et les questions souvent de
journalistes tournent sur le sur les
choses très personnelles ne trouve pas
ici pour le grand déballage
c'est oublié
michel lafon mesdames messieurs
[Musique]
l'orage et vous laisser filer 6 merci
d'avoir été avec nous
il
à
j'accueille tarak ben ammar et emmène en
chine
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous on est
très flattée évidemment de vous recevoir
vie vous êtes les normes producteurs
vous aussi tarak traque vous êtes
l'héritier de la dynastie ben ammar qui
a longtemps été associé au sahara que
j'avais star ac' bénin qui a longtemps
été associé aux destinées de l'état
tunisien vous est le neveu de l'épousé
de bourguiba
vous avez commencé après études à rome
comme comme assistant de production
le matin vous vous leviez pour aller
voir si les le plein des voiturettes
effet quoi vous êtes vraiment commencé
en barre ensuite j'avais emmené d'orge
luca sang en tunisie
georges locas pour la guerre des étoiles
il n'avait pas d'argent et je disais oui
à tous les metteurs en scène de quelle
que soit leur nationalité
une tunisie encore pauvre et qui était
rentré dans le monde de tourisme et je
rencontre georges occase en aéroport et
il me dit est ce que tu as un décor pour
une planète de manière je disais oui par
principe pour continuer une fois qu'ils
étaient là je me démerder trouver un
accord et la planète de la guerre des
étoiles le premier je vous parle il ya
exactement 30 ans je les amenais dans un
village qui s'appelle tataouine ray et
la planète tatooine pour les milliards
de fans c'est un petit village dans le
sud tunisien qui a beaucoup plu à
giorgio cassin et depuis je rejoue kas
revient tournée mais même plan parce que
ça lui porte bonheur il vient tourner
tous les plans de la guerre des étoiles
de la planète tataouine
même s'il fait le film ailleurs comme ça
a été le cas l'an der
ensuite tarak j'avais beaucoup donné
avec avec jésus vous avez produit jésus
de nazareth de zeffirelli la vie de
brian des monty python 13h45 avant
jésus-christ de jean yanne et vous avez
distribué le film de mel gibson la
passion du christ j'ai vu aussi des
échecs vous savez du pirate de polanski
qui est une catastrophe pour vous vous
avez perdu combien tarak là dessus au 20
20 25 millions de dollars
ah oui presque autant que moi un peu
moins
je voulais rentrer dans les toilettes
mais je les ai récupérées ouais grâce à
un procès historique 1
c'est la première fois dans l'histoire
du cinéma qu'un producteur étranger de
surcroît du tiers-monde
j'ai fait un procès à la grande major
company universal arrêt qui a duré dix
ans et j'ai gagné parce qu'il m'avait
signé un contrat qu'ils n'ont pas
respectées c'est pour ça que j'ai perdu
de l'argent et preuve de la grande
démocratie américaine
j'ai gagné devant un jury populaire
19 millions de dollars bravo très
réussie avec la télévision où vous êtes
associé de berlusconi avec murdoch avec
patrick le lay et tf1 le cinéma avait
associé avec joe delaronde tisme
maintenant avec les frères weinstein
dans leur nouvelle société qu'ils ont
créée après leur départ de miramax
alors vous avez vous êtes l'un des deux
frères weinstein légendes d'hollywood
producteurs les distributeurs alors
allons-y de pulp fiction reservoir dogs
kill bill sexe mensonges et vidéo cinéma
paradiso la leçon de piano
adieu ma concubine la cité de dieu
shakespeare in love game the new york 10
aviator le patient anglais
selon m scary movie les invasions
barbares et sin city
oui
alors vous arrivés tous les deux de
cannes du festival de cannes vous avez
trouvé comment le festival harvey iphone
fait face
je trouvais que le festival était
absolument formidable jeu les jurys ont
fait un excellent choix décision avec
laquelle j'étais pas d'accord et que
c'était plein à la cause qui aurait dû
être meilleur rôle féminin toute seule
elle n'avait pas besoin de tout tout cet
aéropage femina autour des arts ea vous
avez déclaré pour moi le meilleur film
réalisé sur los angeles
chinatown de polanski le meilleur film
réalisé sur new york c'est macadam
cowboy de john schlesinger le meilleur
vie de gangster sait il était une fois
en amérique de sergio leone
tous ces réalisateurs sont venues
d'europe
il faut défendre la diversité culturelle
en europe
c'est rare de la part d'un producteur
américain en tant que ça et voyez-vous
je crois beaucoup à la diversité
culturelle mais en plus il s'agit dit
par le passé je le répèterai il me
semble que la france et d'autres pays
doivent justement protéger leur cinéma
contre justement le cinéma américain
même si moi je suis américain je vous
dise à ross pourquoi parce que les
américains ne rendent pas aux français
n'a pas été les à des émissions
françaises et pourtant l'inversé vrai
n'a pas présenté de films français en
tant que fille ni à la télévision en
prime time depuis 40 ans alors comment
où est la justice où l'équité par
rapport aux français anglais ou encore
au cinéma allemand ou espagnol a aucune
justice là dedans moi j'adore le cinéma
quand j'avais 10 ans dans un cinéma chez
les voir ce film les 400 coups de
françois truffaut shrek c'était un film
érotique
parce que le titre bull aux forains le
blues la traduction de 400 coups ça
faisait penser au blowjobs au pipe
là on a fait quatre des kilomètres sous
la neige pour aller voir ce film il ya
que mon frère et moi qui avons vu ce
film parce que tout le monde était déçu
c'est un film en noir et blanc avec des
sous titres pas une seule grille enfin
toujours est il que huit mes copains ont
quitté le cinéma au courant en disant
allez vous faire voir les bob et moi on
est resté et on est tombé amoureux du
cinéma français ce jour-là l'âge de 10
ans avec le film de truffaut riz c'est
une mission d'amener de pousser dans la
banlieue de new york
votre père s'appelait max il était déjà
mentaires il vous a mené tous les
samedis au cinéma il aimait tous les
genres sauf les films de guerre parce
qu'ils avaient combattu pendant la
guerre il fallait plus en parler de la
guerre ce que c'est exactement ça en
effet mon frère et moi on adorait les
films d'errol flynn qui sauve l amérique
mais mon père ne pouvait pas supporter
c'est une
il ya un film qui pour moi à tout et
mystifier s'était il faut sauver le
soldat ryan
pourquoi parce que jusqu'à ce que je
voie ce film je ne comprenais pas ce que
mon père disait mais mon père avait vu
justement de la guerre il avait
participé à des patins et c'est pour ça
qu'ils pouvaient pas voir de film de
guerre
à moins qu'il ne dise la vérité est très
peu de films d'hollywood de présenter la
réalité
oui on en faisait tout un film de
propagande autour de l'amérique mais on
voyait jamais du sens et les pales ne
tue et jamais personne n'était pas
vraiment la vision réelle de la guerre
votre mère s'appelle myriam elle est
toujours vivante et elle pense encore
que le cinéma est un job occasionnels et
vous dit qu'elle n'a pas encore perdu
espoir que vous deveniez médecin mais à
81 ans et si quelqu'un a besoin d'une
bonne mère juive elle est là pour ça
elle peut vérifier les revenus aux jeux
olympiques pour la discipline
je me plains de tout et c'était s'il ya
quelqu'un qui a un souci
elle peut se faire du souci pour tout le
monde en 1919 vous montez avec votre
frère une société qui s'appelle miramax
du nom de vos parents myriam et max
voilà et alors vous allez au festival de
cannes au début des années 80 vous
n'avez pas d'argent vous connaissez
personne et vous êtes dans un placard à
balais à l'hôtel majestic
c'était un placard à balais et j'ai
dormi avec mon frère heureusement que
mon frère parce que sinon il y aurait eu
toutes sortes de rumeurs à mon sujet
personne ne m'a invité à harare filmé
dans le palais des festivals
la prestation est celle que je suis
infiltré comme on faisait à brooklyn
rentrée par les portes de sortie par les
issues de secours et on aussi j'essaie
sur les
et puis les gendarmes sont venus le
tiken jah c'est lui qui était juste à
côté de moi qui étais sur un rythme
tranquille et c'était c'était sean
connery en personne qui nous est
légendaire alors j'en viens de voir
monsieur bond a dit bon nous on les sait
rester dans la salle et c'était la
première fois que j'ai rencontré sean
connery et 20 ans plus tard j'ai raconté
cette histoire
lorsque j'ai eu l'honneur de lui
présenter un film dans le cadre du film
festival le fil des niveaux
je suis raconter anecdotes il a beaucoup
ri parce que c'est le genre de personne
qu'il est les six games alors voilà donc
en 1981 arriver une cynique et son
premier festival de cannes et dix ans
plus tard dans un autre festival de
sundance organisé par robert redford
vous repérez sexe mensonges et vidéo des
soderbergh et c'est le début du succès
vous inventez le block busters sur le
film qui marche indépendants sni
je sais pas si j'ai inventé ce ce genre
cela étant moi il me semble que un grand
film n'a pas besoin d'être confiné aux
ghettos des films d'art et essai sexe
mensonges et vidéo on peut le voir dans
le monde entier il fallait pas le
confiner aux petites salles
le fait qu'un film soit intelligent ne
signifie pas qu'il soit limité
c'est les mauvais films qui devraient
être limitées mais les films
intelligents devra avoir un large public
au contraire
alors votre autre grande spécialité
harvey c'est la course aux oscars
vous dépenser des millions de dollars en
publicité en soirée spéciale en cadeau
sans parler des coups de fil avec un
acharnement au delà du réel pour avoir
des oscars vous promettez aux acteurs
que citera avec vous ils vont avoir la
petite statuette dorée qui est 250
nomination aurait à se jouer à quelque
71 sél et pour moi
l'académie les oscars c'est la façon de
commercialiser en finance donc
évidemment on a investi beaucoup de
temps et d'efforts là dedans mais
quelquefois il ya un petit film comme le
son piano ou game ou shakespeare in love
ou le patient anglais qui n'auraient
normalement pas trouvé un grand public à
travers le monde mais c'est évidemment
losc à qu'était le tremplin qui leur a
permis d'abord sur le public alors pas
simplement pas nécessairement meilleur
film est aussi une meilleur rôle
masculin ou féminin
évidemment ça aide énormément un film un
et prochaine on vous avait de la vie qui
a joué côtier qui a joué cap j'ai vu 20
minutes de ce film à cannes et sa
prestation je suis sûr qu'elle
mériterait un oscar en tout cas elle
sera nominée cotillard dans la vie
devient le piaf ont réalisé par olivier
dahan est produit par ilan goldman alors
on vous reproche quand même harvey un
certain ni respect pour les oeuvres ont
dit que vous coupez que vous remontez
les films les français dit vous vous
appelle d'artagnan à cause du sabre et
on vous appelle aussi 6h hans avaient
inauguré après l'émission
je vais vous montrer la version de cinq
heures de genk the new york et vous
comprendrez
et s'il vous arrivait à tenir trois
heures chapeau 1
alors le plus grand honneur que j'ai
reçu c'est que martin scorsese dit
maintenant que la version de deux heures
et demie la seule version qu'il
présentera donc lui on est contents il
n'y a que la concurrence qui m'accusent
d'être césaire end parce qu'ils sont
jaloux mais nous nous misons la vérité
et en disant la vérité en face
nous emportons les palmes dans les
oscars il a l'habitude de dire la vérité
alors c'est vrai pour un metteur en
scène quand on lui dit son film ils ont
un
c'est difficile c'est difficile et les
metteurs en scène sont entourés de
collaborateurs qui n'osent pas paris est
un peu brusque mais souvent essentiels
alors il faut s'habituer à tort aux
états unis vous savez conteste les films
sur des publics cliniques privées
hosting prévu avant de les sortir et on
apprend beaucoup et malheureusement il a
souvent raison 1 c'est à dire que la
conclusion du public c'est un peu ce qui
l'a anticipé mais il le fait à la fin
avec la collaboration des metteurs en
scène des producteurs est ce que est ce
que patrice chéreau est content de la
version courte de la reine margot vous
avez distribué aux états unis qu'il est
très satisfait et hamilton somme que la
seule chose qui a empêché de films
d'être un peu plus grands succès encore
c'est que johnny tu es censé venir en
amérique pour faire la promotion
or elle avait des problèmes personnels
n'a pas brillé mais c'était là c'était
une déception que l'appel ne puisse pas
venir mais toutes les critiques étaient
très bonne sur l'arène mac os et on
estime que c'est l'un des grands films
français les états unis et c'est la
version courte mais il a dit qu'il était
très content de voir ce film parle de la
version pour lui en tant que juif y
trouvez que c'est un soulagement de voir
des protestants des cats a dit qu'il
s'en tire plutôt que d'aborder des juifs
qui sont assassinés c'était un petit
trait très relaxant alors on vous
reproche aussi d'être terriblement dur
en affaire harvey il ya une phrase qui
courent sur vous à hollywood qui dit si
vous ne vous êtes jamais fait baiser par
miramax si vous n'avez jamais travaillé
avec eux eyepet et leur game alors là
encore ceux qui disent ça généralement
se cachent derrière l'anonymat
ce qui est bien souvent ce sont des gens
qui n'ont pas de succès est-ce que vous
avez le nom de l'auteur de cette
citation la ja que les lâches qui diront
des choses pareilles en 1993 ou vendent
et donc à disney la société miramax ce
qui s'est passé
c'est que tous les metteurs en scène
découvrait tout le talent mais nous
n'avions pas ça sont des moyens malgré
notre succès nous n'étions quand même
quand une petite maison de production et
donc plus chères qui a réalisé my left
foot nous a quittés pour aller à une
berceau pascal guyot et mieux
alors évidemment on aurait proposé
davantage si on avait pu mais nous ne
pouvions pas donc quand nous nous sommes
rendus à disney ils ont décidé de nous
donner les moyens de travailler avec ces
réalisateurs is hot et très bien au
départ un des sept premières années de
la collaboration avec disney ont été
excellentes on a fait peur aux actions
ils se sont un peu mêler de ça mais
disons que on pouvait naviguer assez
bien et on a fait 3 sporting l'a fait
beaucoup de films très controversé mais
après dogma et fahrenheit nine eleven où
ils ont refusé
lord of the rings bon là ça a commencé à
mal tourner et disney vous a refusé le
seigneur des anneaux disons que j'avais
développé un projet avec peter jackson
j'ai mis 10 millions de dollars pour
développer toute la technologie des
tonnages en nouvelle-zélande pour
pouvoir faire ce que vous avez à l'écran
les trois scénarios ont été développés
par nous
je les voir des images et des pieds de
jackson de faire trois films il nous
faut 180 millions $ ce que j'avais un
plafond oui je pouvais pas aller au delà
de 75 millions c'est tout ce que je peux
dépenser quand j'étais aux commandes et
j'aurais dit il m'en faut plus je
voulais faire trois ont dit non non
seulement on n'y croyez pas seigneur des
anneaux mais ils m'ont dit je
conserverai une partie des recettes en
tant que producteur bio et garder des
sous puisque vous me croyez pas et c'est
comme ça que fou qu'on sera en chine
donc ça plus faranah est le film de
michael moore vous avez quittez donc
votre association avec disney ils ont
produit fahrenheit qui a gagné à cannes
michael moore et disney a refusé de
distribuer parce que il attaqué bien sûr
le président bush son frère et lui ont
sorti un chèque ont payé le film l'ont
acheté quelle erreur pour disney
et l'on distribue dans le monde entier
avec le succès que l'on connaissait
courageux
alors que l'écouté donc votre
association avec disney et vous avez
monté une nouvelle société qui s'appelle
the weinstein company vous disposez d'un
milliard de dollars donc ça laisse
rêveur soit pour faire des films
ils ont un milliard de dollars évitant
le cinéma il relevé un milliard de
dollars donc associé avec tarak ben
ammar c'est assez beau d'ailleurs de
voir le juif de brooklyn qui était
associé avec le le musulman de de tunis
c'est assez joli l'histoire 1 c'est la
bible c'est la bible avec vous il ya des
français et des européens il ya tf1 il
ya patrick le lay qui est associé avec
vous il ya lvmh aussi qui est associé
avec vous c'est assez voilà c'était
assez oecuméniques finalement et des
japonais un chinois un c'est vraiment
une compagnie internationale est très
européen
ouais tout en étant américaine avec bob
est ravi qu'ils détiennent 50% de la
compagnie 50 ou 51 51
oui un bug in shore on est là majeur
or voilà donc parmi les premiers films
de cette société il y en a un qui
s'appelle liang hannibal le jeune
hannibal qui est un prix de quoi elles
de la fameuse série du silence des
agneaux avec gaspard ulliel alors c'est
très gonflé d'avoir pris gaspard ulliel
mais ça c'est la dt de takhar cellule a
découvert deux sur cinq en tant que
producteur du film
l'année dernière à cannes m'a présenté
un casting avec cinq minutes de cat tien
qu'ils avaient été tous les acteurs
américaine même plus quand nos boules et
se roule quand j'ai vu ce casting
c'est absolument extraordinaire ce
garçon ira très loin et les
réincarnations d'anthony hopkins mais le
courage de rares vie c'est de confier
parce que le film sortira dans 3500
salles le 9 février aux états unis dans
le monde entier
c'est la première fois qu'un budget de
cette importance est confiée à un jeune
acteur français ça c'est un genre
compagnie ouais même avec le test de
gaspard eu elle ne m'aurait pas suivi
parce qu'ils auraient dit comment on va
le promouvoir
or vis et comment le promouvoir et pour
l'histoire naturellement c'est pourquoi
anthony hopkins est devenu hannibal
lecter donc c'est la vie du jeune animal
et on expliquera on ne dira pas ici
pourquoi il est devenu moi je le sais
bien
donc on va regarder à quoi ça ressemble
alors vous allez regarder tous les deux
votre caméra c'est le cal rouge de
caméra wi de raidlight honda and you say
a envie us et just magnéto serge magnéto
serge [ __ ] one two three manager go
[Musique]
samedi
voilà yoga n'est pas là le jeune
hannibal c'est l'avis de alba les
lecteurs quand il était jeune et
pourquoi il est devenu hannibal lecter
voilà alors on me dira que nous a dit
tout à l'heure que vous disiez toujours
la vérité donc on va voir on va faire
une interview hollywood suisse ait entre
basique in sting t2 et marie-antoinette
lequel vous détestez le plus d 1,5 tout
ça c'est le noeud plus haut rue de d2
c'est incroyablement mauvais rire onet a
quand même des très bonnes choses dedans
oui mais qu'est ce que sofia coppola
doit encore apprendre à sofia coppola
est une belle mais réalisatrice elle
avait cette vision la critique n'a pas
suivi mais le public semble l'avoir
suivie jusqu'au bout mais le fait de
comparer marie antoinette et badiane 5 2
des plus mauvais fume jamais réalisée
au-delà du pire que si vous voyez ce
film l'argent devrait aller une action
caritative
vous voulez à part ça ça m'a bien plu
harvick est ce que vous n'aimez pas à
hollywood
allez-vous d'être un club fermé
[Musique]
je me suis dit ce serait plutôt comme
rome à l'époque ancienne il fallait des
particules en quelque sorte pour
déclencher une révolte
vous avez les grosses médor si gros
studios qui sont identiques mais
s'intéresse davantage à l'argent et ça
n'est qu'une question d'argent de
grossesse ou alors si les gens disent
qu'on est dur c'est eux qui nous ont
précédés studio qui nous ont endurci
le fait qu'on soit sûr c'est ça qui nous
a permis de les combattre
parce qu'avant
ni personne ne pouvait rivaliser avec
les idiots des petits réalisateur et se
dessine à sochaux écrasés maintenant ils
ont plus de pouvoir
parce que nous avons été dur quel est
l'acteur hollywood qui mérite plus 20
millions de dollars par film
la plupart des caisses que les français
font mieux que les américains au cinéma
français ont un cinéma plus intime du
personnel laugnac le spectateur voit son
intelligence flatté c'est être les
acteurs sont intelligents personnages
des scénarios et s'est détraqué gens et
on n'est pas content et son nom par
rapport au public
c'est qu'on relève le niveau alors
qu'avez vous pour attirer un maximum de
public on nivelle par le bas alors que
en france maintenant ça détend dans
notre sens et les comédiens sont traités
en général j'ai vraiment eu copie les
comédies françaises
weber ou les grands
camille ont leurs capitaux à hollywood
avant ces longs gaz au final un magnet
bonne cuisine et on va appuyer
je laisse vicieux au cul moi je les
appelais up or vie qu'est ce qui vous a
énervé récemment chez tom cruise je
connais en fait c'est sa religion
orthodoxe et c'est too much et thomas
était un petit peu étroit d'esprit c'est
quelqu'un de très sympa que je connais
très bien
on a vécu quand même il meurt pendant
longtemps une sur les années mais cette
année je crois qu'il a pris peur fermé
mais il va se rouvrir je pense dans les
années à venir
c'est ce que je pense sinon vous pouvoir
de films si ma production m'enfin c'est
un très bon accueil à gaspard car et
vous qu'est-ce que n'importe quelle
actrice a de plus que nicole kidman
moi j'ai fait sept films avec nicole
kidman y compris le film pour lequel
elle renonce car c'est une idée
absolument ex trader extraordinaire sur
tous ses aspects et films comiques
sérieux nicole kidman et tout un cieux
zimmel accepté 15 millions $ d'un studio
et plus normal travaillent gratuitement
sur ds que je fais avec elle ou encore
une fois sur un petit projet elle est
très généreuse qu'elle filme avez vous
regretté de produire être prêt à porter
avec robert altman
mon problème c'est que j'ai jamais
rencontré marché le masque bratman
l'ami avec sophia loren dans l'infini et
j'ai oublié de faire mon job de
producteurs je passais mon temps avec le
vin cello toute la journée jeux la
compagnie de matériaux soi il m'a emmené
à déjeuner il me racontait toutes les
anecdotes sur fellini des sikhs à tous
les ses héros de mon enfance et pendant
huit semaines j'ai oublié mon travail
alors robert half men mardi mais je te
vois jamais tu passes tout autant avec
marcello alors je n'ai pas pu vraiment
participer au film
[Musique]
donc pas à l'imiter
à
[Musique]
qui
j'accueille bien brochand
jean bonsoir bonsoir à vous n'avez pas
fait que ça dans votre vie mais vous
êtes aujourd'hui le maire de cannes quel
bilan tirez vous du dernier festival
je crois que c'est à dire on l'a dit
tout à l'heure là c'est un très bon
festival
d'abord très bon festival par par les
films on a rarement une sélection aussi
bonne par le jury qui a été élu aussi
exceptionnels et hors marché s'il faut
jamais oublier que derrière le festival
il ya un marché et des mallettes et des
médailles celle moyaux ça c'était avant
ça c'était avant c'est fini les manettes
c'est fini je crois que ça vous a déçu
parce que je crois que c'est vidées des
sacs en papier et donc il ya un marché
c'est la première fois qu'on dépasse
dans le marché de 10 mille participants
le marché était tout à fait bon il ya eu
des vendeurs des acheteurs et donc c'est
un très bon festival bien il n'y a
qu'une chose je vous adresse une
supplique bernard est ce que vous
pourriez faire détruire le palais du
festival le bunker et en faire un autre
parce que franchement c'est d'une
laideur c'est inimaginable
oui oui la salle de cinéma et pas très
bien en plus cela est sanctionné le
détruire bernard écouter on est de
détruire nous sommes complètement
d'accord pour le reconstruire
mais si vous voulez quelqu'un vers
citect un vrai architectes ne le dit pas
celui qu est l année passée n'est pas
mort il est déprimé tout le monde il
nous est vrai que c'est le viol et les
faunes référence très sérieusement si
vous voulez là c'est un groupe savait
demande quand même parce que détruire le
bunker faut-il pendant ce temps là que
le festival continue grand pin on peut à
des faits mais il faut aimer un autre
truc à trop de régler le problème cela
on va régler ça
le reconstruire va oui oui sauf qu'il
faut trouver un système de transition
on va pas si ce qu'on peut reconstruire
au même endroit comment parce que le
festival on peut pas l'arrêter
puis a pas que le festival vous savez il
ya le mipim midem assez vite comme le
poisson géniaux il ya plein de froid
kong un spectacle son vivre la ville et
du spectacle alors logan pour vous c'est
un peu le retour de l'enfant prodigue si
vous êtes né à cannes
votre grand père était le patron du
grand magasin les dames de france
votre père était expert comptable votre
père et a disparu très tôt en 1959
voilà et alors votre vie est racontée
dans un livre de pierre dominique
cochard qui s'appelle vous pouvez
réussir l'impossible position naturelle
contre le pessimisme chez timée éditions
alors on apprend que vous n'êtes pas
passés loin d'une carrière de
footballeur professionnel
vous avez gagné la coupe gambardella
avec l'as cannes en caler sur place et
oui absolument
j'aurais pu être un très bon joueur
professionnel je les ai été pratiquement
tout en continuant mes études mais c'est
vrai que le football ne m'a jamais
quitté c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui encore
j'attends avec impatience la sélection
la sélection absolument je sais pas quel
point ça parce que je vous aime pour
couper ou pour barthez vous eh bien je
moi j'aurais dit coupez j'aurais pris le
risque est alors on 63 effectivement
après vos études à hec ou fait le
service militaire dans là dans la royale
dans la marine et vous êtes en quarts de
finale de la coupe de france avec l'as
brestoise et c'était la grande équipe du
racing qu'on a battu si vous voulez 1-0
en finale alors en 69 vous avez trente
ans vous travaillé pour la société
procter and gamble et vous entrez en
contact avec l' agence de publicité ddb
la fameuse agence de bill burns bac qui
est une star mondiale évidemment qui a
fait cette campagne extraordinaire pour
volkswagen avec marc et il se glisse
petit gadget travail et montrer le
fameux lem qui m'ont traité qui monte au
ciel et il avait mis
il se glisse bâti get you there signé
volkswagen c'est à dire il comparait le
lem qui était extrêmement laid et qui
montaient donc c'est un show créatif
c'est pas vous sortir et que vous dire
ça vous connaissez sa venue qui courait
vous avez dirigé ddb en france pendant
des années donc grandes agences et là
qu'on s'est connus absolument plus de
trente ans qu il ya eu la fameuse
campagne canada dry encore dans les
esprits aujourd'hui est la couleur de
l'alcool ouais le goût de l'alcool mais
ce n'est pas l'alcool quoi alors on
parler de cinéma avec arrive instinet
tarak ben ammar vous travaillez à
l'époque avec jean jacques annaud jean
jacques annaud molinaro soudé tout des
jeunes metteurs en scène acquis à
l'époque nous avons fait confiance et
c'est vrai que ça a été pour nous là
aussi une nouvelle vague puisque vous
avez fait partie cette nouvelle vague
après 68 il ya eu dans la publicité
française en tout cas un renouveau
complet
là aussi toute une génération nouvelle
apprise et rigolo avril pouvoir c'est
très rigolo
ensuite vous entrez dans le groupe havas
ou diriger le la publicité chez havas
donc euros comme il vous fait la fameuse
campagne darty le contrat de compte et
l'envoie alors ensuite il ya des
problèmes vous créer une agence qui
s'appelle femmes ou les femmes devaient
faire la publicité pour les femmes
oui j'avais des idées je croyais que la
pas très bien marché a très bien marché
secret héros comme junior oui c'étaient
là des enfants qui faisait de la
publicité ça pas très bien marché
et puis vous vous heurtez au caractère
particulier davasse parce qu'à val
c'était l'actionnariat public donc une
espèce de courroie de transmission de
l'elysée de matignon
c'est l'époque où mitterrand vient
d'être élu et à l'époque vous songé à
partir
quand andré rousselet vous convaincre de
travailler sur le projet de ce qu'on
appelait encore à l'époque la quatrième
chaîne c'est-à-dire canal et vous
participez à la fondation de canal+ tout
à fait qui a été une aventure absolument
extraordinaire et là aussi on voit bien
que quand on crée une nouvelle chaîne
c'est quelque chose qui nécessite comme
toujours malgré tout des talents ouais
et l'invention qu'apporter pierre
lescure
c'est vous qui avez eu l'idée de lescure
oui c'est moi qui suis allé le chercher
parce qu'à un moment donné justement ce
qu'avait fait charger de cette chaîne
n'était pas justement suffisamment
talentueux pour faire de l'innovation de
la nouveauté et surtout sa première
chaîne payante
là aussi il fallait savoir quel concept
on allait mettre en avant
le concept en avant bienvenue c'était le
sport particulièrement le football et et
le cinéma et sur ces deux concepts après
il y avait la multidiffusion il y avait
toute une série de choses qui permettait
justement là aussi d'être de changer
complètement la nature je crois des
télévisions de l'effet alors 88 vous
prenez part à la campagne présidentielle
de chirac
mais c'est malheureusement mitterrand
qui gagne vous quittez havas vous
retournez chez gd des bêcher goldmember
bague et là vous devenez président de l'
agence monde
tout à fait c'est quand même énorme
c'est à dire que là moi je suis ce qui
m'étonne le plus dans votre carrière
c'est le français qui devient patron
mondial d'une agence américaine
ils sont venus véritablement me demander
et je suis devenu donc président monde
de 1989 à 2003 et donc pendant douze ans
j'ai dirigé 15000 personnes 15 milliards
de chiffre d'affaires 140 cas c'est
énorme
c'était énorme mais surtout ce qui était
intéressant c'était que s'ils voulaient
là aussi c'était la mondialisation un
français s'ils voulaient qui quand même
à les vendre
l'amérique en chine 3 il fallait
budweiser par exemple que nous avons
lancée en chine où bien d'autres temps
d'autres pays vous pouvez réussir
l'impossible salah vous êtes client
alors au début quand vous arrivez dans
cette agence il ya 44 pays dans le monde
et à la fin il ya 145 pays
donc vous avez gagné 101 pays vous avez
implanté l'agent servir aussi ça veut
dire aussi beaucoup de travail ça veut
dire pendant 12 ans en 80 jours par an
dans les avions
ça veut dire aussi un changement de ma
vie personnelle et qui comme toujours le
principal acte que je pouvais faire
c'était est recruté comme toujours ce
n'est pas contrairement à ce qu'on dira
c'est inventer c'est recruter partout où
j'allais les meilleurs en particulier
les meilleurs créatifs
c'est donc une vaste recherche s'ils
voulaient d'hommes capable d'adhérer à
une certaine philosophie publicitaire
une certaine culture d'entreprise et est
véritablement il fallait que j'y aille
pour les convaincre de venir avec nous
plutôt que de réelles avec d'autres
alors vous êtes président du psg à ce
moment-là vous cherchez quelqu'un pour
reprendre effectivement le psg alors au
départ berlusconi est sur le coup tout
le monde a peur que ce soit berlusconi
tf1 refuse la clt rtl refuse lagardère
échaudés par la sphère matra racing
n'est pas trop envieux de s'occuper et
vous le vendez à canal finalement c'est
vous qui avez organisé ces gens qui
organisent et le tour de table a lui
fait envie de canal c'est vrai que ça a
été une aventure formidable et là aussi
si vous voulez comme toujours
quel est l'objectif que vous suivez quel
est le style de joueur tout joueur qu'il
fallait choisir quel était ce qui
attendait pari pari manqué de ce
football professionnel et là aussi il a
fallu créer une stratégie réfléchir
avant et on a un est allé chercher des
brésiliens et ce n'était pas pour rien
si vous voulez on a choisi un entraîneur
particulier puisqu'à part il faut à la
fois des résultats
une fois la fois un football chatoyant
et c'est pour ça qu'on a pu faire venir
de ricardo valdo raï à leonardo un type
comme leonardo qui était parti à milan
m'a téléphoné pour me dire président
surtout n'allez pas au stade de france
on est chez nous au parc des princes
quand même extraordinaire la part d'un
joueur brésilien alors 1998 vous venez
passer des vacances à hagan et c'est là
que vous décidez de vous présenter à la
mairie
votre grand père vous avez dit tu as été
favorisée par la vie un jour il faudra
que tu rendent et vous décidé de rendre
aux gens aux citoyens savez j'avais
choisi un temps 60 ans je crois que
j'avais fait le tour de la publicité on
m'a proposé à ce moment-là de devenir
patron de la holding américaine omnicom
qui est le premier groupe publicitaire
mondial
il fallait vraiment que j'allais vivre à
new york complètement c'était plus un
job là financier qu'un job à un volet
qui était un job là aussi proche du
terrain proche des campagnes est donc là
aussi ça faisait des années que je
voyais cette ville comme vous avez
décrite où il se passait des choses
quand même qu'ils n'étaient pas tout à
fait normal ou pas c'est terrible
c'était le clientélisme la corruption et
c'était incroyable comme vous dites
et c'est vrai que cette ville était mal
barré il fallait là il fallait la
reprendre et je pense que j'ai bien fait
je suis très content d'être maire de la
ville de cannes il se passe des choses à
cannes mais là aussi vous savez cannes
est une ville est là aussi très locale
très provincial avec des pêcheurs avec
des habitants mais aussi une vie très
international moi ce qui me frappe tous
les jours niveau des congrès c'est que
je retrouve mes clients ce que j'ai
rencontré partout dans le monde entier
et et je dirais très curieusement quand
j'ai dit à dd
je partais et qu' il avait très peur que
je parte à la concurrence wire mais
quand je leur ai dit que j'essayais
j'allais essayer de devenir maire de
caves
il a écouté ils ont été très fiers et et
le board à l'époque m'a applaudi voyez
comme quoi les américains là aussi ont
un certain respect de ce qu'ils y font
pas et le public et infatigable parce
que non seulement vous êtes maire de
cannes mais vous êtes parti dans une
nouvelle mission c'est la chaîne d'info
internationale française le cnn à la
française
je crois que tu sais tout à fait
essentiel pour notre pays qu'on est une
chaîne internationale concurrents de cnn
bbc world al jazira car notre présence
mondiale et notre présence sur le
terrain mais ces sites en effet que l'on
puisse parler de la france
mais parler de l'économie parler de ceux
qui font ce pays et qui veulent
conquérir le monde donc c'est vrai quand
on a vu comment les américains ont
traité les émeutes en banlieue
voilà la fin 2005 on aimerait qu'ils
aient une chaîne française pour
expliquer les prises de position de
notre gouvernement par rapport à la
guerre en irak et discours qui ont été
faits à l'onu jamais ils ont été
retransmis sur une chaîne internationale
et c'est là on a bien vu si vous voulez
la nécessité d'avoir un moyen
d'information vous avez appelé france 1
j'espère n'ont peut-être moi j'aime bien
ça me semble anormal qu'à y aura le move
pour moi je dois m quels moyens france à
l'intérieur ouais en tous les cas vous
avez une devise qui était assez drôle
celle inverse de coubertin c'est
l'essentiel n'est pas de participer mais
de gagner
oui je crois si vous voulez aujourd'hui
à force de participer ont participé ont
fait rien et je crois gagner c'est faire
quelque chose et puis quand on perd on
perd je veux dire par là il faut pas se
désespérer vous savez comme toujours au
football c'est le prochain match est
important
hélas hélas il très important de
redonner cette volonté de gagner assez
quand on est perdant cantonné poulidor
quand on perd les jeux olympiques quand
ton père qui avait tout ce que l'on perd
à un moment donné eh bien on fait plus
rien quand on est désespéré et ça c'est
ça aussi un élément important pour la
confiance en soi mais quel regard vous
portez aujourd'hui sur votre ami chirac
bah écoutez moi j'ai des relations j'ai
toujours eu des relations sous les
excellentes années q je crois que
aujourd'hui ce monsieur le président que
je respecte ne se représentera pas aidé
en laissant il se représente pas et bien
il faut penser
ce qui va se passer après je crois
qu'aujourd'hui nous devons penser pas
dire la france d'après parce que ça va
parler de slogans qui existe mais est
évident que aujourd'hui la france
pendant cette année je dirais 2006 et
tout le monde de gauche de droite les
grands les petits les vieux les jeunes
doivent se préoccuper de ce que va
devenir ce pays car aujourd'hui on ne
peut pas rester dans l'état où on est on
peut pas rester en l'état économique
dans l'état social est véritablement
nous comptons et personnellement en tout
cas je compte beaucoup qu'on puisse en
effet retrouvé réformer ce pays pour que
là encore on retrouve quand même une
france dynamique confiante et pas
pessimiste et pas déprimé comme elle
l'est aujourd'hui à toul à tout moment
crois qu'aujourd'hui on a perdu 7 parler
de mon grand père mon père quand j'étais
avec lui à cannes il ya 50 ans
maintenant c'était un monsieur qui
chantait tout le temps qu'ils étaient
heureux qui qui joue aux boules qui
faisait il y avait une joie de vivre des
fruits de voiliers un fainéant 20
inférieurs il travaille aussi beaucoup
mais mais mais pas que c'est ça qui nous
manque et je pense que d'ailleurs on le
voit dans votre émission
je le dis je voyais vous essayez quand
même malgré tout tous les événements que
vous abordez en donnant cette le côté
positif
je suis pas retourné le couteau dans la
plaie parce que ça s'arrête nationaux
mais justement ça va s'arrêter
renault vous êtes responsable des médias
l'express vous pensez quoi bernard
brochand ces personnages qui comptait
qui a pesé dans le pit publicitaire
tagro monsieur respectée qu'à une
magnifique carrière c'est vrai merci
très diverses en plus travailler sur
divers une belle destinée en tout cas
j't'embrouille
[Musique]
quoique bien de l'unique le char vous
pouvez réussir l'impossible
selon bernard brochand
[Applaudissements]
chez timée éditions mesdames messieurs
oui
alors merci d'avoir été avec nous
[Musique]
qu'est la nuit là
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir il comporte un volet aujourd'hui
entre paris et moscou vous collaborer
régulièrement l hebdomadaire le point
auparavant pour le compte de
ouest-france et de libération vous avez
couvert le conflit tchétchène et vous
avez obtenu en l'an 2000 le prix albert
londres pour chienne de guerre chez
fayard vous publié aujourd'hui toujours
chez fayard par les monts et les plaines
d'asie centrale donc j'étais allé
visiter toutes les républiques ex
soviétiques qui se termine par ce temps
et qui suscite l'intérêt des grandes
puissances mondiales
oui on du pétrole oui oui les
républiques qui se termine par
méconnaissance de nos 1
selon les régimes on sait très loin mais
cc frontalier de la chine au nord de
l'afghanistan au sud de la russie en
gros un espace grand comme l'europe
occidentale tout entière c'est bien le
servir au niveau des bus les bus oui
internet les avions c'est un peu plus
compliqué c'est toute l'ancienne
compagnie aeroflot en face et tout
l'espace ex-soviétique donc on connaît
pas du tout et surtout on a l'impression
qu'ils s'y passe rien c'est pour ça que
évidemment dans les médias il ya rien
mais moi c'est ça qui m'intéresse et
j'attends pas qui s'y passe quelque
chose pour y aller j'y vais je parle
avec les gens j'écoute ce qu'ils me
disent et je retransmets j'essaye tout
simplement de de rapprocher ce jour là
sur lesquelles on connaît rien de nous
alors si république en fait suscite
l'intérêt de toutes les grandes
puissances mondiales parce que les
chinois on voit des commerçants les rues
si ça m'a bien les garder
les américains y installe des bases
assez c'est quand même un lieu
effectivement ça bouge beaucoup quoi oui
ça bouge beaucoup il ya deux dates
importantes c'est d'abord la fin de
l'urss en 1991
donc la série publiques dans lesquelles
personne allez on commence à pouvoir y
aller qui y va en premier évidemment les
américains parce que il ya des
hydrocarbures il ya du gaz et du pétrole
y en a vraiment beaucoup
donc les multinationales pétrolières
américaines ils vont s'installer
nous les français on met beaucoup plus
de temps à s'installer deuxième date 11
septembre 2001
au lendemain du 11 septembre une fois de
plus les américains se disent il faut
quand même un endroit un peu de retrait
par rapport aux opérations qu'on est en
train de faire en afghanistan
donc il demande à ces pays s'ils peuvent
installer des bases militaires ils ont
réussi à s'installer dans deux pays au
kirghizstan et en ouzbékistan au
kirghizstan qui est quand même le seul
pays au monde dans lequel il ya deux
base distante de quelques kilomètres à
peine
l'une américaine l'autre ex soviétiques
à rêver que russe les régies de voix
celle d'un très mauvais oeil déroule
bien sûr parce que pour les russes
c'est encore ce qu'ils appellent
d'ailleurs très poétiquement l'étranger
proche c'est-à-dire presque pas
l'étranger c'est à dire plus aujourd'hui
ils sont très vexé de devoir acheter un
visa pour pouvoir aller au kazakhstan
parce que avance et l empire soviétique
pointures dont qu'ils essayent de
récupérer en tout cas de ne pas perdre
leur influence sur place c'est comme si
et des bases russes au mexique quoi
voilà s'étonne pas exactement
alors vous avez une technique vous
fondez comme ça dans la masse comme une
espèce de caméléon vous habillé en femme
locale vous voyagez en taxis collectifs
c'est très efficace et plus sûre sur
monde
une méthode tout simplement enfin on
appelle ça maintenant il m'étonne moi
c'est ma façon de travailler normal j'ai
commencé par le pire la guerre en
tchétchénie je crois qu'il ya pas pire
comme école dans le journalisme et dans
la correspondance de guerre l'idée de me
faire remarquer en tchétchénie
évidemment c'était ce n'était pas le
bienvenu donc c'était clair quand tu
utilises les m'habiller comme une femme
tchétchène
donc je le fais naturellement en irak
chiites irakiennes on a vu en
afghanistan suivre je parle beaucoup de
langues dans chaque pays essaye je suis
en train d'apprendre l'arabe
je parle sept langues couramment dont le
russe khl puisque j'habite en russie
depuis dix ans n'en perd soviétique
était grand on peut encore parler russe
dans toutes ses dents toutes ces
républiques
mais ça aide de parler la langue parce
que si j'arrive avec un intermédiaire si
j'arrive avec un quelqu'un qui va
traduire qui n'est pas de la famille les
gens vont se méfier ils vont évidemment
jamais me parler me dire les choses qui
me dirait si je suis le seul en face à
face avec eux ouais donc l'important
c'est de gagner leur confiance et en
même temps c'est efficace et sûr parce
que en étant habillés comme eux en
parlant comme eux ils vous racontent des
choses qui raconterait pas évidemment un
journaliste qui s'afficherait comme tel
et puis c'est moins dangereux que si
vous arriviez en jean et et anti char du
mans première raison c'est la sécurité
ma propre sécurité il est clair que si
j'arrive à billets comme si je suis ce
soir à bagdad je me fait immédiatement
remarquer donc ciblé potentiellement à
qui a kidnappé alors que moi j'essaye de
faire le contraire c'est d'ailleurs
d'être la plus discrète possible de me
fondre dans la population un con et un
billet comme ça est également en prenant
les buts justement les moyens de
transports locaux les bus ça marche
toujours même dans les pays en guerre
les minibus les navettes les taxis en
commun puisque les taxis cc trochain
donc il ya souvent plus tôt 4 5
personnes dans un taxi et puis je me
tais conseiller dans un taxi j'ai pas
besoin de parler pour qu'on pourra fille
chez qui je suis j'ai besoin simplement
de passer d'un orage eu quand même mais
vous avez quoi comme papier sur nous si
jamais vous fait j'aime à pied français
français mais j'ai toujours
j'ai toujours l'espoir que je vais pas
me faire contrôler au s1 ça m'est arrivé
une fois en tchétchénie la fois où un
soldat russe m'a finalement demandé mes
papiers alors que j'étais habillé en
femme tchétchène et que j'étais assise
derrière et non pas devant parce que
c'est comme ça que ce soient des femmes
sont assises derrière et que normalement
on adresse pas vraiment la parole à une
femme
il n'aurait pas dû me demander mes
papiers mais a demandé là j'ai hésité et
je les lui ai donné mes papiers cv
papier français bien sûr et je me suis
dit bon évidemment il va appeler au
taquet walkie et c'est terminé je me
faire arrêter et le mec qu'il avait 18
19 ans il était je crois un peu paniqué
de voir un passeport étranger et puis il
a rien fait on est reparti et avec mon
chauffeur qui était un copain on a
évident évidemment éviter le post
suivant pour passer autrement
mais il faut prendre le risque j'avais
peur c'est pas le moment où j'ai plus
peur le moment où jean plus peur c'est
évidemment sous les bombardements et
quand j'ai vu des gens ouvrir évidemment
sous ces bombardements parce qu'à la
guerre aux moeurs il faut le rappeler
aujourd'hui en irak sarij publié
également chez fayard islamistes comment
ils nous voient alors qu est un compte
rendu de voyage au pakistan en
afghanistan en irak
alors vous avez interrogé des religieux
des talibans des oulémas vous interroger
des combattants des moudjahidine des
intellectuels des politiques des
professeurs de simples croyants c'est à
dire moi ce qui m'a intéressé dans ce
petit livre islam is comment ils nous
voient c'est vraiment de faire l'inversé
de ce qu'ont de ce qu'on a produit
surtout depuis le 11 septembre 2001 il
ya des myriades de livres sur l'islam
sur comment nous les voyons plutôt
comment nous ne les voyons pas ce que
nous ne comprenons pas et j'ai
simplement voulu faire l' inverse
inverser le regarde c'est à dire essayer
de leur demander comment ils nous voient
comment ils se voient eux mêmes comment
ils voient leur propre vie ou leur
survie dans la guerre et je me suis
rendu compte qu'ils avaient bien sûr
autant d'idées reçues et de stéréotypes
sur nous que nous avancions lorsque nous
le gros amalgame l'amalgamme le plus
fréquent c'est musulmans égale
terroristes en gros en très gros oeufs
c'est occident sans faire la différence
entre les pays français américains
italiens c'est occident égale ennemis de
l'islam
donc on est mal parti pour s'entendre
quand on quand on quand on quand on a ça
au départ mais quand on va sur place
comme ce que je fais comme les
journalistes terrain font mais on se
rend compte que il faut forcément entend
ce qu'ils nous disent même si c'est pas
agréable entendre bien sûr que c'est pas
grave l'entente et bien sûr que la
plupart de mes interlocuteurs montée des
propos violemment anti occidentaux et
j'avais envie de les couper toutes les
secondes et d'en dire que j'étais pas
d'accord mais moi mon but c'est qu'ils
mendient encore plus c'est que vraiment
ils parlent pour qu'on puisse se
rencontrent
de ce qu'il pense éventuellement réagir
alors on va prendre les malentendus donc
il ya d'abord un malentendu géopolitique
c'est dire leur rejet de l'impérialisme
et de l'occupation américaine que ça oui
ça paraît évident sur place il est assez
difficile d'être d'accord avec celui qui
vous occupe militairement que ce soit en
irak ou en afghanistan aujourd'hui il ya
une armée étrangère qui occupent le pays
ce à dire que les habitants n'arrivent
pas à vivre normalement
tout est compliqué d'aller d'un point a
à un point b de savoir ce qu'on va faire
demain
c'est vraiment très compliqué il ya
quelques jours il ya quand même une
femme enceinte qui s'est fait huer lors
d'un checkpoint justement routier à
bagdad tout simplement parce que c'était
pas arrêté là où il fallait exactement
s'arrêter il a eu à du talent oui il ya
ce massacre de haditha qui date de
novembre 2005
j'ai passé il ya quand même à l'époque
de mme hilal et tout ce à quoi s'est
affaissé tout à fait comparable mais là
aussi c'est intéressant de voir que
notre vision est différente de la leur
parce que pour nous c'est une découverte
c'est en train de faire un scandale ici
aux etats-unis mais pas pour eux pour
eux c'est pas une découverte pour eux
ils le savaient que ce massacre avait eu
lieu un tout le monde le savait et pour
eux c'est tous les jours la même chose
c'est tous les jours la guerre le
massacre donc si vous voulez ce qu'on
leur donne de la démocratie ce que nous
on voudrait qu'ils acceptent comme la
démocratie est qu'ils acceptent en
l'applaudissant est bien pour eux c'est
très négatif c'est-à-dire quand on
demande aujourd'hui un afghan base ou un
irakien de base qu'est ce que c'est la
démocratie va vous dire la démocratie
c'est le kidnapping quotidien le chaos
la corruption l'insécurité donc que des
choses négatives mais il sait pas ce que
c'est la démocratie comme chez nous donc
évidemment il peut pas vraiment en avoir
envie
alors 2e malentendu le malentendu
idéologique alors il nous reproche
finalement notre individualisme
mais et le libéralisme voir le
libertarisme de nos comportements quoi
oui il effectivement là on a affaire des
sociétés c'est pour ça que j'essaie de
m'adapter le plus possible comme comme
comme un peu un caméléon tout simplement
de a à e
parce que ces sociétés sont très
différents des nôtres - puisque je suis
une femme j'ai le droit quand je suis en
irak ou en afghanistan d'être avec les
femmes
alors qu'un reporter hommes ne
pourraient pas le faire ce que je fais
c'est à dire il aurait accès qu'aux
hommes
moi j'ai bien sûr accès aux hommes en
premier parce que ce sont les hommes qui
font la guerre parce que ce sont les
hommes qui sont dans la rue ce sont les
hommes qui palabrent etc
mais ensuite quand je rentre dans les
familles parce que j'habite chez les
gens je ne suis pas à l'hôtel évidemment
j'ai séché les gens ça c'est important
je les femmes attendent avec impatience
après le dîner de me voir et de me
parler hein et donc j'ai leur version
des choses qui évidemment différente de
celle des hommes et qui la complète et
ça c'est très important c'est à dire que
ils ont d une vision encore des rapports
hommes femmes qui sont pas du tout les
nôtres
je me rappelle de cette femme irakienne
ni drette à kirkouk au nord de bagdad
kim qui est professeur d'anglais donc
est quand même assez ouverte
intelligente qui me disait quand je l'aï
revue là au mois de novembre
à quel point elle était choquée de
savoir qu'en occident
ça va faire rire tout le monde mais
qu'en occident un homme et une femme qui
sont rencontre qu'ils se connaissent pas
peuvent re immédiatement avant des
relations sexuelles et elle me disait qu
est ce qu on fait des enfants mais avec
la plus grande naïveté sans même se
rendre compte que effectivement la
contraception existe c'est à dire c'est
inconcevable pour elle donc là on est
vraiment loin de la façon dont nos vies
chez nous et puis elle malentendu
médiatique donc la désinformation les
amalgames c'est à dire bon tous les
terroristes sont des musulmans et tous
les musulmans sont des terroristes ou
les occidentaux sont des envahisseurs et
c'est la force de la télé ça c'est très
important parce que malgré toutes les
différences que je viens d'énoncer on a
tous quelque chose en commun
nous ici les terroristes les
fondamentalistes ou les simples
musulmans c'est qu'on regarde la télé
tout le monde regarde la télé même là
bas même en afghanistan où il n'y a pas
d'électricité dans des villages ou un
bruit pour brancher sur une batterie
tracteur tout le village se retrouve
autour de de ce petit écran bleuté et
qu'est ce qu'ils voient même s'il
comprend pas ce qui est dit il est
choqué par les images ivoire d d d
horreur des choses qui font peur qui
peuvent attirer et faire peur en même
temps ma seule présence parfois dans ces
familles je les ai sentis auprès des dés
de ces femmes qui me posaient des
questions autant de questions finalement
que moi je leur posais parce qu'elles
sont curieuses pascal voir si elles
veulent bien justement vérifier si ce
qu'elle voit à la télé c'est c'est vrai
prouvé qu'elle pouvait avoir des
réactions très différentes soit une
envie c'est à dire non indépendance de
femmes occidentales ma liberté leur
faisait envie leur ouvrait des horizons
nouveaux
ou alors les terrifier tout simplement
parce que c'est tellement différent que
c'est pas possible
alors c'est vrai que l' affaire des
caricatures de mahomet à a montré que le
fossé se creuse que chacun vit avec ses
stéréotypes ces idées fausses sa
propagande et peut-être que cette
histoire de choc des civilisations
vraiment arrivé moi je prend
malheureusement qu on est en plein
dedans
le choc des civilisations c'est ce
fameux livre de samuel huntington gros
personne n'a vraiment lui en tout cas
mes interlocuteurs sur place qu'ils
soient très intellectuel ou pas du tout
que ce soit des rides de base
ils en ont tous parlé c'est donc que
c'est vraiment une idée qui les a
marqués ils ont l'impression d'être dans
le service alisation c'est à dire qu'on
ne peut déjà plus se parler c'est déjà
trop tard
moi j'aimerais se livre un peu une
sonnette d'alarmé
j'aimerais croire qu'on ne connaît pas
encore dedans mais quand je rentre parce
que je crois que pour les reporters de
guerre le plus important c'est le plus
dur c'est pas de partir partiront part
parce qu'on aime ça parce qu'on aime
aller dans ces pays mais c'est revenir
revenir ici est ce être face à
l'indifférence cette espèce de bulle de
confort dans lequel on se complaît tous
ici et qui fait qu'on a l'impression que
personne ne vit autrement que nous un
peu c'est très difficile à l'extérieur
donc justement le petit effort
d'inverser le regard est même difficile
ouais on a des raisons d'être inquiet
alors je crois oui on a des raisons
d'être inquiet parce que le monde va
très mal surtout quand on sort de cette
bulle enfin déjà ici chez nous ça va pas
très bien mais ça je n'ai pas écrit deux
livres donc je connais pas très bien de
la france 2 connaît mieux l'afghanistan
l'irak
ailleurs ça va très mal le terrorisme
c'est un drame et malheureusement si on
continue disons à ne pas dialoguer a
montré une espèce d'arrogance ou ce que
perçoit comme une arrogance ça va être
encore pire il ya un truc qui trouve
grâce à leurs yeux c'est la technologie
les portables ouais c'est la seule chose
de l'occident enfin quand on y vote
libre c'est la seule chose de l'occident
qu'ils acceptent quoi ouais ils ont ce
rapport très en vue à l'occident tout ce
qui tout ce qu'ils aiment pas dans
l'occident vient on vient d'en parler
mais en même temps ils peuvent pas ne
pas être attiré par certaines choses et
certaines choses c'est bien sûr la
modernité la technologie nous savons les
téléphones portables c'est vrai que
j'avais des interlocuteurs hallucinant
directeur de mai dressa d'écoles
coraniques à peshawar qui sortait un
téléphone portable de leur fond de leur
poche
ensuite un deuxième puis un troisième
avec des sonneries hallucinante il
s'échange tout ça sur les fichiers mp3
et on est assis en tailleur sur c'est
incroyable ça c'est la cohabitation des
deux rem modernité et puis ce côté qu'on
pourrait juger un peu rétrograde en tous
les cas dans la vie quotidienne
voilà mais il faut qu'on le sache non
occidentaux saisir ils sont pas que
rétrograde
ils ont ils acceptent aussi des choses
de chez nous donc ça donne un mélange
assez difficile à comprendre
et tout ça pour être s'arrangera avec un
charles portal on pourrait pas plus
et chez fayard
monsieur
[Musique]
comment il est roi
c'est aussi
chez fayard l'admission
[Musique]
j'accueille lorraine barberger
avant toute chose ya là maintenant non
mais ce qui est surtout on doit libérer
la nounou libérer la nounou libérer la
nounou
mais
[Musique]
pas pour l'instant
presse affaires
tu en es content ce qu'il faut qu'elle
soit contente de moi ça de bas salaires
oui oui ça se passe bien et puis vous
vivez bien l'échangé alors elle vous est
né en pennsylvanie en 1977 vous vivez à
new york depuis 1999 et après vos études
universitaires voulait devenir
journaliste et vous vous retrouvez
assistante de la rédactrice en chef du
magazine vogue et un jour dans un
atelier d'écriture on vous demande
d'écrire une quinzaine de pages vous
raconter votre expérience chez bob donc
et ce texte deviendra un best seller
mondial
sous le titre le diable s'habille en
prada qui s'est vendu à des millions
d'exemplaires dans le monde entier belle
histoire
merci je ne sais pas comment vous savez
tout ça sur moi je suis impressionné
alors avec tout l'argent que vous avez
gagné vous avez continué à écrire et
aujourd'hui vous publié chez fleuve noir
pipoles or not people qui est déjà
numéro 10 dans la liste du nouvel obs
alors le pitch est l'histoire de bêtes
qui à 26 ans
qu'est ce que vous faites là c'est pas
moi je sais pas moi bon tu peux me dire
et j'en ai rien à [ __ ]
mais tu es viré comme tu vois rien à
[ __ ] alors le pitch c'est bête donc il
ya 26 ans qui travaille dans une banque
tu es viré aussi le pitch donc ces bêtes
qui à 26 ans qui travaille dans une
banque à à manhattan où elle s'ennuie
elle vit seul avec son chien depuis que
son petit ami l'a larguée pour un
mannequin et là elle décide de
démissionner et au lieu de sombrer dans
la déprime elle et elle est ravie elle
regarde des émissions idiotes à la
télévision elle lit des romans à l'eau
de rose elle se délecte de son
inactivité
jusqu'au jour où son oncle lui trouve un
job dans une agence d'événementiel et
alors là fini les soirées sous la
couette place aux clubs branchés aux vip
et voilà elle se demander c'est tout le
sujet du livre
est-ce qu'il faut être people ou papy
paul qui paul or not people
finalement ce projet elle entre dans
seulement c'est un monde qui est très
éloigné de sa réalité de ce qu'elle
avait fait avant un travail dans une
banque dans des treks conservateur et
finalement on entre dans un milieu très
glamour et en fait il faut être vu faut
voir il faut rencontrer les gens
importants c'est quelque chose qui est
très sain style devient un mode de vie
très extravagant très branché et branché
avec du champagne des soirées etc
et finalement elle entre dans ce moment
là et elle se rend compte que ce n'est
pas véritablement ce que l'on pense que
secondaire alors j'espère que je ne vous
dévoile pas la fin mais en fait tu aides
arrivent à s'en sortir mais vous
personnellement vous n'êtes pas très
people en fait je crois que si elles
étaient au moins moitié aussi glamour
que celle de mes personnages bien ce
serait plus drôle mais c'est génial
d'être ici c'est génial d'être en
tournée d'être à paris c'est formidable
c'est super vous n'êtes pas très people
parce que vous dites
écrire est la meilleure excuse pour
rester chez soi et parler à personne
pendant des jours et des jours
oui j'aime bien sortir dans un autre je
crois que sortir tous les soirs jusqu'à
4 heures du matin avec dans ce milieu de
la drogue etc
je ne sais pas quelque chose qui me
prend je véritablement est ce que je
préfère écrire je ne sais pas mais bon
sortir de temps en temps avec des amis
ça c'est sympa c'est la première fois
que vous venez en france
l'occasion de venir ici lorsque j'étais
étudiante et puis en décembre dernier je
suis venu ici parce que vous êtes en
train de tourner le film le diable
s'habille en prada
ah ouais ah oui très bien c'était
formidable
absolument you like food in france vous
aimez la nourriture française
bien sûr les cuisines les vêtements la
mode les hommes il ya pas grand chose
qu'on puisse ne pas aimer en france si
j'irai six mois que ça tombe on décide
soigner ma beaucoup mis beaucoup plus
soignée que les mères
message que je partage cette voie là
alors
c'est publié chez fleuve noir mesdames
messieurs
[Musique]
j'accuse jacques l'eau
ouais
alors la meilleure façon de présenter
jacno c'est ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
orange et
m
le codeem m tous les jeux sont les mêmes
[Musique]
m
la veille
[Musique]
je
m
c'est vraiment
je n'ai
non
un turban
il demeure
combien
[Musique]
vim
comment
[Musique]
jacno on se rencontre on se rend compte
quand on écoute ça c'est qu'en fait vous
êtes plus célèbres pour votre côté
technoïde initiateur de la french touch
que par le punk rock des stinky toys
finalement oui probablement mais ouais
bien sûr c'est à dire que même jean
stinky toys c'était du groupe de rock
hyper sauvages qui sont là un truc qu'on
fait à 18 ans mais ce qui est normal et
puis après évidemment en ce qui me
concerne j'ai fait tout de suite autre
chose que tu étais un peu passer pour
des truc de martien allait peu à ce
moment là le trait il y avait beaucoup
d'électronique mais qu'un fond comme ça
un peu guitaristique c'est très très en
avance finalement ouais ouais mais c'est
plutôt un inconvénient ça ouais alors
aujourd'hui vous sortez un album qui
s'appelle tant de temps que la presse
spécialisée salue comme du grand jacques
neau rock et folk a dit un album pop
ultime et hors du temps bah ouais je
suis ravi ses chaussures avis qui disent
ça parce que c'est un peu le but du jeu
moi je voulais faire un truc
comment dire un peu hors normes et
justement hors du temps c'est à dire
hors de la mode des sont à la mode du
système de mixage qui est très formaté
qui actuellement je vais plus de pure
chanson
qu'ils soient un plaisir quoi wingles et
sa place
entraîné par lente et douloureuse
forte des parents
[Musique]
voilà jacques selon le sport jacquiau de
14 juin la cigale au revoir à quoi ça
ressemble j'ai regardé votre caméra
jacno sais où j'ai là c'est le cadre ou
judith magnéto serge mcginn et auxerre
vitesse on met pays
alors on a mal on c'est pour les cons
arrêté le sport
les cardiaques
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
las
travail
le sport c'est de la merde ajaccio
sport
monsieur l
m
c'est chez warner music
[Musique]
je sais déjà l'hymne de l'équipe de
france puis j'ose espérer alors vous
dites que le sport c'est de la merde
mais en même temps quand on voit ce
qu'ils prennent dans le cyclisme ça
devrait vous plaire non mais l'eau est
justement mais moi je suis plutôt contre
la drogue est donc là si on parle de
sport c'est quand même une bande de
drogués de milliardaires en short qui
courent après un ballon c'est très
spécial
et tout ça est payé par une vente
principalement de pauvres de jean
compact une qui voit les milliardaires
en short complètement drogué courir
après un ballon ou faire du vélo ou
enfin la vision mais c'est bien mais il
s'est juste moi c'était juste une
remarque je fais pas de critiques
une constatation comme disent le
contraire tu connais jacques nolwenn
c'est l'icône l one way mais ouais mais
j'aime bien plus qu'elle a fait alors
pas réellement à cet album ou publié aux
éditions du rocher un livre d'entretiens
avec albert algoud qui s'appelle jacques
nos itinéraires du dandy pop vous
raconter votre vie alors au départ vous
êtes une famille quand même très réac
pas réac vieille france vieille ville
vieille france le grand père considérait
que le figaro était un journal de gauche
et histoire celle qu avec le fouet aux
marchés le cuir est extra mais c'est à
dire que d'elle moi j'étais petit et
donc c'était tout à fait surréaliste et
en fait moi j'ai une buse saab
j'ai vu que le côté poétique de la chose
ouais mais t'es marrant parce qu'il est
royaliste un jour vite pourquoi t'es
royalistes il dit parce que je suis sûr
qu'ils auraient jamais droit oui je
trouvais ça assez beau c'est un peu
l'histoire
et oui mais toi tu es enfin il y avait
tout à fait de savoir ce que c'était sûr
qu'il aura jamais trois non bien sûr
c'est plus possible d'arriver aussi
votre oncle dd oui mais c'est dans we
andré zeller dans des putschistes oui un
des putschistes mais moi je n'ai pas
connu puisqu'il était en prison oui moi
je connaissais sa soeur tante mimi
voilà qui m'amenait que les noms qu'au
delà des 10 et andré zeller qui était en
prison avec salants
jours aux echards c'était les quatre
putschiste est d'alger les généraux
factieux comme disait de gaulle
wellwood quarteron de généraux factieux
bravo laurent away boogie boys sur le
service public la ligue auxerre voilà
alors ensuite vous est envoyé dans une
pension catholique chez les frères
maristes là vous prenez option musique
quand même hein heureusement mais bon il
y avait des trucs imposé alors je fais
de la flûte à bec puis après flûte
traversière ça pour conclusion que c'est
quand même le seul instrument que je ne
supporte pas moi c'était plus un cadeau
alors heureusement qu' il y avait la
possibilité de guitare mais c'était plus
cher
1 donc ça n'a pas été possible donc
heureusement hein sinon j'aurais jamais
rien fait parce que cette bande de cons
enfin bon c'était quand même je passe
sur les détails pédophiles de ce type
d'armes que vous avez tendance à vous
comme tout le monde c'est jean pierre
mocky qui racontait très bien comment ça
se pratique c'est un peu je te caresse
le rêve après puis tu t'assieds sur moi
puis bon évidemment alors il ya le coup
de gueule et moi sur ce que j'avais fait
donc
la déco les deux week-ends ouais mais
c'est un bond il ya christophe girard
qu'est venu ici qui disait que ça lui
était arrivé il s'était assis il avait
sur le curé avait senti un truc un peu
dur et qui trouve ça très bien lui
comprenait pas pourquoi le curé était
palais était pas allé plus loin
ah ben on peut vendre être friand voir
son truc tu es assez drôle quand
j'entends ça sympathisants ouais
l'artiste vous rencontrez vous raconter
votre vie donc la rencontre avec warhol
qui veut vous sautez lui aussi oui oui
bien sûr il avait un badge avec votre
effigie que t'as qu'à 10 lui avait donné
étiez vous étiez quand même extrêmement
séduisant mais je me souviens à l'époque
j'en remets toujours il ya une trentaine
d'années c'est vrai que jacques neau et
magnifique audi tient très très beau
garçon
j'en prends quoi roll et eu envie de
vous sautez quoi ils ont voulu à mon cul
c'est clair mais encore une chanson mais
bon ça s'est pas fait à vous raconter
votre rencontre avec elie alors elli et
jacno donc elie faisait partie du
service d'ordre trotskiste
oui quand je les ai connus et c'était de
la lcr enfin elle même je pense comme
elle avait 16 ans enfin toute façon
n'était pas au courant de ce que ça et
en plus elle arrivé d'uruguay donc oui
déjà ne parlait pas trois mots de
français et moi même j'étais pas au
courant du sujet de la manifestation
s'était pas l'un du jeu on était juste
là pour [ __ ] la merde et se marrer un
peu quoi à vous raconter l'époque pinte
donc les stinky toys et fameux stinky
toys et puis alors vous avez à londres
et vous rencontrez des sex pistols et
vous découvrez qu'en fait c'est un
groupe complètement bidon vous dites
c'est comme un boys band quoi aux ordres
de malcolm mclaren johnny rotten mclane
lui dit tu sors pas du placard il sort
pas quoi oui c'est vrai mais c'est pas
comme un boys band c'est un boss c'est
un boys band mais c'est pas pour autant
que c'est mauvais c'est un très très bon
groupe de rock
moi je me souviens de concert c'était
vraiment pas mal mais néanmoins faut
savoir que c'est vraiment un boys band
c'est une fabrication mclaren we are
casting ouais sauf que justement le mec
qui faisait les morceaux qui justement a
été virée qui était claire malton way i
les démences obama a invité oui mais il
était dérangeant alors vous raconter
l'invention de l'épinglé à nourrice par
paris
ça s'est passé à londres les histoires
de punk c'est c'est un deal de mclaren
prennent principalement un magasin de
fringues qui s'appelait sexe qui ont été
associés avec vivienne westwood et donc
peu leur but du juste devant des
fringues soit avec un groupe de rock
comme les sex pistols ou etc
donc quand tu vois il y arrivait du
pantalon franchement raccommoder
exclusivement à base de d'épinglés à
nourrice
mais ça c'est bien la semaine d'après
c'est en vente a séduit jetterait
démystifiant sur le pain godbout qu'un
oui non mais je trouve que c'est pas
démystifiant de devoir justement ça rend
les choses un peu plus humaine de voir
que via tueur des businessman derrière
des types qui font 2 1 ils font des
trucs parce que ça ne retire pas le
talent de le talent des uns ont parlé de
pâques à 10 du night clubbing et puis la
défonce avant vous êtes gravement
accroché là d'autres non ouais moi en ce
qui me concerne ça a duré assez peu de
temps mais d'une façon très concentrée
maximum pendant un an peu de toi ça a
duré plus longtemps loin mais quand j'ai
reçu tous les soucis leur arrivée tu
crois que non mais pendant un an oui
ouais très fort
j'ai testé toutes les drogues qui
existent sur la planète en un an et puis
tout d'un coup ça l'était j'ai senti le
danger se dirait et donc je suis allé au
château du ville bilingue est une
clinique est relativement fascistes mais
qui tu ressors clean et tu as survécu
oui oui contrairement à toi qui me
semble un peu non
jacno algo itinéraire d dans une pop aux
éditions du rocher
on m'a chambré les tests
[Musique]
j'appelle sophie soulignac et la famille
vincent
allez
m
bienvenue à m il ya de la neuve ce soir
c'est cool quand la ch'ti et la stib a
il n'y aura pas d'accord à ce décompte
en salle avant tout écouter des
chanteurs ticket va adorer
[Applaudissements]
alors tout est dit ou fait star mag tous
les jours à 19h55 sur tps star
ça consiste en quoi sophie c'est une
heure d'émission de cinéma joue les
jours avec une bande de jeunes qui adore
le cinéma qui essaye de transmettre leur
enthousiasme en allant voir plein de
films parce que même un boulot très
difficile pour connaître les tiac en
effet la wii vous avez qui comme serre
dans votre émission là beaucoup des
biens coppola aussi bien audrey tautou
beyoncé knowles jamie foxx et tu vois
bien alors qu'amiens animaux on a vu
dany boon voit quand même vous attendez
on a gardé le meilleur pour la fin à ses
jours vous avez vu ce film
bien sûr pas mal les débats je ferai
plus jamais de travaux chez moi mais
après tout va bien alors pour mettre les
10 km jérôme foucault
hirano le murano d'urban resort une eau
de murano loving you must go des limaces
il a tu connais toi oui si mignonne plus
et les riches
bon bah oui tu as raison on sait pas
c'est si elle va être diffusé ce nom
ces internats et pour la chaîne
il a bien tué près jérôme et voilà vous
connaissez le principe d'abord c'est
l'équipe de jacno contre l'équipe de
nolwenn je suis responsable il faut
mettre déjà responsable de quelque chose
une fois dans ta vie certains
responsables de voeux d'énormément de
choses de vie mais là du blind test
c'est un peu dur comme un débat voilà
c'est ton équipe voilà et donc l'équipe
de noël
attention mais c'est faire s'il est avec
nolwenn moi j'ai honte
ouais
pas venu pour perdre un talus bien ça
fait un point pour l'équipe de nolwenn
évidemment numéro
la saveur
on
djédjé
m
non
gaccio nettoyeurs
[Musique]
quincy jones
quincy jones en continu jérôme la
musique
en france
bon alors ça fait quoi rebecca qu'est-ce
qu'on a emballé là-dessus à l'eso qu'on
apprenne ça fait deux points pour
l'équipe de la loisne quand même
la loi n'a gagné la star ac' alep-hama
boyle gagner de la vitesse vous allez
voir les enquêtes
[Musique]
et dany tu la connais l'intérêt marrant
que tu y aller génial alors de qui on
continue jérôme non mahinmi
[Musique]
quand
gfr
il faut que dès lors qu'ils trouvent ça
non c'est la télé sur le bouton le rang
lors du ces qui connait barry manilow
copacabana
alors vous en êtes tous là hein on y va
c'est normal d'aller en afghanistan tout
le temps revel de l'express et pas rock
et folk
mais vous la soulignac bas vivrait temps
c'est ton métier toi tu me suis mis nos
neurones
même s'il pleut
ce sera chaud dans les tee-shirts
l'utiliser
ils ont mis ko
charleroi
ça veut dire
une merde
non c'est bien parce que j'ai entendu ma
femme j'ai honte d'avoir trouvé pourquoi
non enfin désir laurent laurent pas dit
non non je sais c'est ouais puis estime
à dieu toi souchon et voulzy parce
qu'ils avaient fait une parodie de cette
chance
sébastien c'est pour ça que je t'avais
ont 70 8 g t il dit
les débats
[Musique]
m
à manama des paroles sont nuls mais moi
je vis ces trois points plus ça va cette
performance fifa
j'ai dit laurent blanc menteuse alors
match d'hommes l'ebitda
[Musique]
je laisse les possibles
qu'est ce que c'est bon un très bon riz
à laquelle riffs jo
telle est ma télé
[Applaudissements]
moore
voilà
[Applaudissements]
5 pour nolwenn trois projets qui n'ont
aucun sens
soulagés en âge attention attention ces
voleurs ce n'est qu'une tricherie enfin
c'est pas triché trichet j'ai un petit
doute là dessus non non non ouais mais
bon ce temps la triche à la stac là les
clean on continue jérôme way
c'est
allez
c'est un modèle reconnaît me fait chier
parce qu'il est rapide mais j'avais
reconnu ici mais ça aussi vite
il a dit que s'habille comme elle aussi
il a deux qualités au ces qui fait des
vagues dans la fulgurance et ils se
trouvent les les chansons des bleus à
une thèse sur les intros voilà as plus
qu'à trouver du travail
lettre de recommandation l'aesa s'étend
sur près de 6 c'était c'est précis comme
savoir faire mais il peut trouver des
choses il ya des télés en afghanistan et
non en arabie saoudite tu peux trouver
bien sûr en burqa aussi les nôtres le
pied du boulot jérôme l'estonie
une grille
[Musique]
je conseille aux jeunes générations cet
album the pursuit wikango un homme qui
durant deux minutes 35 je conseille ça
aurait l'air non ouais faut y aller
maintenant
we need you we need you under my thumb
andermatt femme s'est jetée en prison
encore un petit bout non c'est difficile
m
mr
mais
[Musique]
bien on continue jérôme ils font plus
rien maintenir leur nom à leur tour la
boue
[Musique]
l'original était deuxième ouais bah
bravo bravo ouais enfin c'est de la
musique de michel jérôme
ouais
[Musique]
il
je les mettre sur mon i pod le strict at
je sais pas si je suis bien
oui ben ouais c'est magnifique et après
tu te fais un tatouage mais oui je me
fais là voilà donc l issue du par
équipes c'est l'équipe de nolwenn qui
gagne avec une toile
soit on obésité
madame messieurs si je dus par éclipser
la fin du paris sinon c'est le chacun
pour sa gueule chacun pour sa gueule
c'est de vous étonner c'est le
libéralisme
voilà j'ai plus d'amis attention on y va
le bongo jr robbie williams
non
[Musique]
dans la salle mais oui
laquelle
hélas
exact mais la raison c'est la trop de
robbie williams eut peut remettre un
trophée vient d'arrêter robes et un à la
raison il a bien pompé au billard s'est
servi les noms des braves au qatar ouais
fumier bien bien vu bienvenue nolwenn
alors on continue
c'était le bon coup on passe au super
banco attention gérault
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
seuls groupes anglo-saxons qui chante en
ch'ti ouais alors maintenant on passe à
l'ultra banco c'est très très très très
difficile c'est un groupe que j'adore
personnellement mais bon peut-être
suis-je le seul en attentions se
concentrent tous m'étonnerait que tu
trouve toi ça vous êtes anglais des
années 80 cette merde oui exactement ils
sont venus à lunettes noires pour nuits
blanches
depeche mode ah non il a quand même pas
de chanson par jacques attention que tu
peux trouver toi allons-y jérôme labat
véhicule
magath
c'est dur
manas
voilà
y aller c'est à l'uci la caméra le cadre
végétal
reuters thierry non pardon ça il
retourne à sa place à bord et qui valait
mille dinars du groupe d'abord c'est
prefab sprout boisvert
jamais
il y avait aussi une chanson géniale
s'appelait manhattan de prefab sprout et
king of rock and roll c'est vraiment un
très bon groupe
bienvenue donc à l'issue alors rebecca
qui a gagné c'est thierry barba d'ivoire
retient
[Applaudissements]
voilà c'est tellement parlons nice et
nantes émission terry quoi qu'on en dise
et quoi qu'on en pense
c'était tout le monde en parle c'est les
mains c'était tu mens pas les gars on a
dit non
[Musique]
le passager de l'été avec catherine frot
grégori derangère françois berléand et
mathilde seigner
sortie le 7 juin mesdames messieurs
nolwenn leroy tellement merci s'appelle
histoire naturelle elle est en concert
les 9 et 10 octobre à l'olympia et en
tournée dans toute la france
dany boon la maison du bonheur de dany
boon avec michèle laroque
j'ai dit
laurent gamelon un line renaud et
lysiane rolet entendu sortie le 7 juin
bon norvège pipeau le grand déballage
avec lens de bruit chez michel lafon
tarak ben ammar et habib ennjimi
as tu et les minimoys
bernard brochand vous pouvez réussir
l'impossible
selon bernard brochand de pierre bénite
cochard chez timée éditions anne nivat
des islamistes comment ils nous voient
et par les mots les plaines d'asie
centrale
les deux chez fayard laureline
weinberger iphone en plus beaux essais
chez fleuve noir
jacno l'album s'appelle tant de temps
voilà plus itinéraire du hip hop avec
albert algoud ces deux éditions du
rocher
sophie soulignac nathalie vincent
starmag tous les jours à 19h55 sur tb ce
gars est jaune fluo l'album comme
entendre par angela s'appelle peace and
love s'était toujours pas au rendez vous
la semaine prochaine
[Musique]
d'emblée
honnête
mais
mais bon
[Musique]
ils ont l'habitude
sony
oui
[Musique]
rester dans nos pays